want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from dean graziosi
enjoy
immediately when i wake up i can't check
my phone in fact i put it on airplane
mode and i move it
i got that from ariana huffington who's
amazing and she's like
is your phone still by your bed she goes
airplane mode on the other side of the
room you know
um so that and then
i just know so many people roll over and
grab their phone and to me that's like
russian roulette you put a bullet in the
gun and you spin it
it's like what if the email says the
deal didn't happen numbers are down
life's not working out like and
immediately for me it's like you open up
and
and this little box is gonna dictate the
first couple hours or maybe the whole
day by what you see so
i just i just won't look at my phone
when i first wake up
um so but when i first open my eyes this
is all and i like doing things
quick for me because i want to get to
the gym because the only time of day
i'll go if i try to wait till the
afternoon it doesn't work for me
so as soon as i wake up i immediately
try to think of something
i'm grateful for which everybody knows
that and thinks about it but i've
i play this game myself on how far i can
lower the bar
meaning i i try to do a gratitude
journal about three years ago and after
about five weeks i ran out of stuff to
say
i'm like i already wrote my kids and
this and life like what did i put in
here like
and then i was like wow 150 000 people
die every single day
you can google it that's the number it's
like some days i wake up i'm just like
i'm here awesome and i let i feel that
silly little thing like i'm here or i'll
be like oh my god the sheets feel
softer than they've ever felt and i'll
literally think to myself these sheets
are really good like
what a third of the world sleeps on the
on a dirt floor
and i have sheets and an amazing bed and
look at the view i have
and that's enough just because the way i
do it is i'm just just tweaking my brain
enough to be in a grateful place it
doesn't have to be this
for me and you guys might have better
practices i'm not talking about a half
hour gratitude meditation i just need
one little thing or i pick up a book if
i'm reading one of the books that you
have on the shelf
i'll pick and i'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and i'll get that state of mind for my
brain and then
i think about one win i had the day
before
because i know as entrepreneurs as
somebody searching for success
we never give ourselves credit we never
treat a friend the way we treat
ourselves it's like i know i've had days
i've gone till 10 o'clock at night go
man i got nothing done today
was the biggest lie like we beat
ourselves up we just we're like these
racehorses we wouldn't even treat a
racehorse that we owned as bad as we
treat ourselves right so
i wake up and i'll do a quick little
gratitude and they'll say what was one
win yesterday that i accomplished and
i'm like wow
you didn't do that yesterday and then
i'll think of one win i want to do that
day
like what i'm going to need a million
things done today but what's a must
today that would be a great win
and then for me then i immediately go
downstairs in my house and i drink
i felt like i fed my my mind and i want
to feed my body
so for me i've been doing the same drink
forever i do apple cider vinegar
lemon mct oil a scoop of green powder
and uh mix that up and i down that and
then i immediately got to go to the gym
i think we live in a shallow world i
think
i think shallow meaning we're especially
a new generation who grew up
going through a stream right so yeah
what used to be hours went to minutes
and now it's seconds right if something
doesn't catch you in a second
and i feel like a lot of people want
that next level
which is great everybody should but we
dabble in each one and we don't see
enough spark
excitement or light so we back out and
go to the next one it's like it's like
they're looking for the magic money
machine and they're in one car and
they're like this car might work
oh that car looks good then we jump out
in the next one and we jump out in the
next one
so i would say even though you know i'm
50 this year so i've had like different
lives i went
deep on all that everybody watching
we suffer on all different levels of
suffering we some people suffer on a
high level some people suffer because is
the job going to get done
is the is the deal going to come through
like we have these moments of suffering
no matter if it's
five minutes of suffering or an hour of
suffering or months of suffering some
people
lose a relationship and they suffer for
years some people have a partner take
their money
they suffer for years and they're stuck
in that and if
you can limit the time you suffer the
more you can work on the solutions that
better your life
people stuck in suffering absolutely are
stuck forever and we know
right now i'm saying it and you're
thinking of friends that you have that
are stuck some
they went when it went found some
suffering and they just crippled moments
where i was suffering and i didn't let
go of it
you can't let go over right where i held
onto it for too long to hurt me right
and if you hold on to it
there's not enough energy or focus to
keep moving forward you could that's
when you still
right yeah so what i've been on this
obsession and literally tony robbins
flew out him and i
got really close he flew out and him and
i had lunch about
nine months ago and he's on the same
thing like eliminating like complete
suffering gone like instead of it hours
or weeks it's moments that you catch it
so morning routines help so what's up
man it's good to see you
i i see you all over the place i see you
hustling i see you try
impacting lives doing amazing stuff on
youtube i want to share whatever works
for
you know you're following my following
today but i want to share
dude your book built to serve you are
built to serve there's a difference
when you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for
entrepreneur for over 30 years i've been
in the self-education industry for 24.
can't even seem doesn't even seem
possible but there's a lot of people
that
when you kind of meet your heroes or you
meet the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room
like there's no congruency is what i
wanted to say and before we chat today i
just want to honor you and give you
congruency this
what you wrote in this book is really
who you are man you are built to serve
you reach out to my team all the time
and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're not doing it because of
finances you're not doing it because
you're trying to get an edge you're
doing it just because
this is who you are man so i love seeing
you out there i love seeing you grow i
love seeing the impact you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so
um i'll just say thank you then i'm
going to keep doing it through this
entire thing to make you feel
uncomfortable oh
great classic dean all right cool well
you know also in that story
um you know you've been really helpful
in getting that book out i remember when
i came to puerto rico
and uh was trying to get feedback on
pre-launch
you when brendon richard took time
backstage
while you're doing your big event people
paid all this money to come there and
you took time
over lunch for 40 minutes to do a deep
dive
on my strategy um and just super
grateful that you guys did that and
you hooked me up with your warehouse and
you know a whole bunch of things that
dean's the big reason why the book is
has uh uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so listen
um appreciate everybody i see all the
cool comments coming in so how can we
deliver some value today how do we help
out besides
um i do got to plug this like if you
didn't check out
uh evan's built to serve you should
check it out um the truth is
i'm not all the way done i freaking love
it my biggest problem is every book i
read evan i listen
i i have such a hard time reading i
still have dyslexia
it still doesn't stick so it's taking me
longer but when i actually read a book
it sticks so i highly recommend it
and uh it's just you it's like it's it's
having a
200 page conversation with you which is
which is always cool
cool man appreciate it well we also i
also have an audiobook version i
i read it myself so there's always oh
dude please send that to me
life is short it's going by a gazillion
miles an hour we got one
shot at this we might as well squeeze
every bit of juice out of life
we possibly can so with that said the
lesson i taught my daughter my son to i
could have a great story of him but i
love keeping these around seven eight
minutes so you can get some wisdom get
some and go out and take action with it
um winners win when no one else is
watching
how many basket how many foul shots do
you think michael jordan took
when no one else was in the gym right
how many shots did wayne gretzky
take when no one else was on the ice
right
how how many how many times has lebron
james practiced and woke up sore and
couldn't move that no one else sees
yes he gets the glory everybody goes
nuts i i
me and uh tony every year invites me to
the finals and i see i'm
blessed i'm not even saying i got it
tony gets the you know
half half court on the floor seats tony
robbins those those seats are probably
40 grand each i don't even know invites
me every year i sit there i watch lebron
james play
four three or four times now it's
unbelievable and he gets the praise and
the audience go i watched cleveland
go insane when they won but guess what
he did that when no one else is watching
you don't get the glory my daughter last
night everybody praised her they won the
first game they lost the second one in
the last inning i was so disappointed
but she they won the first game i
watched everybody high five on her
she loved it but if she didn't practice
she wouldn't get any of that
so remember that doing this work
listening to this watching this
going through my courses other people
who are playing the game you're doing
the work when no one else is watching
and when you soar
let them admire you let them envy you in
fact be the inspiration to pull
some people with you knowledge amazing
you need it
following others who have uh conquered
the game before you and are crushing it
you need it you must get in a mastermind
learn from people playing the game at
the highest level possible masterminds
and group training
have literally moved the needle for me
more than anything in the history of the
world
knowledge when it's thought through when
it's practiced when it's in play becomes
wisdom you're learning wisdom from most
if you go to the right mastermind the
right group the right mentor
you have this concept of protect your
confidence i've never heard anybody say
it like that before
why is that so important well because i
think i mean
in all the big decisions you've had to
make along your way
have you ever made a good decision when
your confidence was down no
once like can you say i walked in my
head was down your physiology's changed
you're
like a little nervous like you just
don't make good decisions when your
confidence is down
and and i don't think it's like we're
either confident or not confident
i think it's like if confidence is 100
if our confidence is 95
we play smaller i know with me like the
big opportunities come if i'm not in
that like
space i'm like you know what guys let's
just let's hold let's not like i won't
make smart decisions so i think
i think we have to do everything in our
power to protect our confidence
what i have learned through the years we
all got in business for different
reasons yeah
i wanted to be successful because i
hated not being in control of my life as
a kid
my parents were married nine times
between the two of them i moved 20 times
nine times nine times so never stability
you know get a new house you gotta leave
go here leave move in with grandma so i
think
i i hated the insecurity of my childhood
but it was my driving force so thank you
god the universe whatever you believe in
thank you for that
because it pushed me to go hey i don't
want i don't know about you i i
you and i hit it off in the first three
minutes we were talking but i'm not a
control freak but
i don't want anybody ever tell me how to
live how to dress what to wear if i want
to wear orange sneakers today i want to
wear orange sneakers
i live where i want i raise my kids the
way i want i don't get into peer
pressure
i don't hang out with the joneses or try
to impress the joneses i just want to
live my life
but i know that happened at a really
young age so
backing up with your question is that
drove me
so sometimes you need pain to drive you
yeah and then you start being successful
then you can go to aspirational now i
want to be a better dad be a better man
be a better human but if you need pain
to drive you let it drive you
on your journey you're going to come
across all new friends you're going to
lose old friends for a while
you're going to you're going to get
people in your life who love you that
try to suppress you
and they're going to want to hold you
back and here's the thing you have a
couple options in your life
you can let them dim your glow that you
can let them turn down
your fire or you can realize it's not
their fault
so let me just ask you again i want to
go back to this who in your life makes
you
feel bad about your dreams your goals
your desires because those people are
affecting you whether you realize it or
not
when you have a desire for that next
level someone negative someone
trying to protect you tells you you
shouldn't you can't you might say no i'm
not listening to them but even if five
percent of that
rubs off on you then you might make
different choices you might play a
little bit smaller than you need to
your confidence could be crushed just a
little bit more than it needs to be
crushed you know
confidence is a weird thing confidence
doesn't go from zero to a hundred in my
eyes
confidence if your confidence is down
five percent you're screwed because
you're gonna play small you're gonna
play safe
do you think in today's world do you
think being good at something with
most of your confidence is enough do you
think being excellent with the 90
of your confidence is enough hell no you
need to be freaking outstanding you need
to rock it with your confidence at a
hundred percent
and how can your confidence be at a
hundred percent if you're letting people
in your life
make you dim your glow to lower your
expectations to play
safer if you want the magic money
machines there's about 400
million of them on facebook right now i
see all the ads make up 500 000 in first
six months
six weeks to six figures all these
incredible ads and listen i am so
not anti-money i love money money can
allow us to be a better version of
ourselves when you don't worry about
money
you get to work on you dig into the old
crap of your childhood work on your
your sadness your depression your angst
your worry your stress
work on that start doing the things that
can fulfill your heart your soul
so with that i went on that rant for a
reason because
i love how much this podcast is growing
but i want to be
really clear this is about success this
is about the money
but i just go upstream a little bit
further than most people you know i
heard a story once where it said
a doctor pulls up to the stream there's
a whole bunch of people drowning
and this doctor's running out and he's
grabbing people giving him out the mouth
saving them running out
he's getting overwhelmed more and more
people coming down
and another doctor pulls up and doctor
goes what's going on he goes oh my god
thank god you're here
he goes come out here and help me save
these people there's so many drowning
the doctor the other doctor that just
pulls up gets in his car starts driving
off
the doctor's like this was saving
everybody's like what are you doing i
need your help
why are you leaving goes well you could
do that but i'm going to drive upstream
and i'm going to find who's throwing
these people in ah
think about that who's throwing these
people in
i want you to realize that this podcast
is about going
upstream and finding and creating the
the foundation so you could be
successful in all areas of your life not
the
hit or miss not the maybes no the solid
foundation
for long-term happiness abundance joy
and money
if you're starting a business or you
have a business room make sure that you
know the difference between want
and need so many people think i'm going
to create a business based around this
thing because everybody needs this well
everybody needs to stop eating so much
sugar everybody needs
to eat healthier everybody needs to go
to the gym but people don't do any of
those things unless they
want to so don't get delusioned and fall
so in love with your own product or your
service
knowing that people need it because they
probably do but just because they need
it doesn't mean they want it and if they
don't want it they're not gonna cut you
a check for it so differentiate the two
between
want and need i think forgiveness is one
of those things that no one would ever
consider
as being a success habit nevertheless a
millionaire's success have it what the
hell does
forgiveness have to do with it it's too
fufu i i want the
i want the tactical money making stuff
right i want to get to the nitty-gritty
but
here's what i know there's only a
certain amount of time in a day there's
only a certain amount of
energy in a day and not even just time
and
energy the clarity of creative thinking
compared to the clarity of busy thinking
listen you might have time
you're squeezing it in to think about
your bigger future your bigger business
making more money but if you
don't have clarity in those thoughts if
your heart isn't open
then the universe god whatever you
believe in the marketing geniuses the
marketing
inspiration doesn't funnel down into the
top of your head
and come out of your mouth and without
marketing and creativity then what do
you have
without the planning to follow through
without the stamina
to get over the hurdles when it goes
sideways what do you have you have a
good idea
everybody's got a good idea you're
listening to me right now
not just because you want some magic
money machine you want the foundation
for wealth and sustainability and
success
if i'm if i'm wrong then i apologize
maybe you're looking for the quick hit
but how long does that work
even people who hit the lotto go broke
on average right
so what the heck does forgiveness have
to do
with success everything i think
forgiveness is one of the most
underutilized uh not just words but
things in our in our world in in our
ability to grow as a human
i want to give you an example the reason
this is on top of my head
is my son uh who just two nights ago
when i'm recording this won the state
championship for their uh 10 year old
division uh of baseball which was so
awesome so watch them he did great they
did awesome
um but i want to back up my son has been
on the same team since he was four years
old
the same coach love this guy one of the
greatest guys his wife is amazing he's
amazing loves kids
and they play twice years they pretty
much play all year round he coaches the
all-star team too so he plays
spring ball fall ball and summer
all-star so he's pretty much with this
guy all year round
and he's got a son named dean same name
as me and i love dean i always tease him
i said that's my name i had it first
you're bob so when i get there he's
always like no you're bob but in the
last six
months dean's changed dean has been mean
he's been
a bully and especially to my son
brody and i think it's a competitive
thing dean is good
brody's better brody's bats first ever
brody's nine on the 10 11 year old team
and he still bets first probably the
best average on base of anybody on the
team
not because he's my son he's just good
he's small but he's good he's a hustler
but last six months dean has been really
tough on brody so i don't want to just
solve this for my son
i want him to figure it out on his own
so i keep saying hey you got to stand up
for yourself i i say hey
you know how does that make you feel
make sure you realize that that's
his opinion that's not who you are like
all the stuff fundamentally out of the
book doing it right
trying to empower my son because i'm not
going to always be there to protect him
right
well the last all-star game as we are
building up to all we have the
semifinals my son gets up goes four for
four
in the dugout dean comes up to my son
because
dean is sitting there's only one person
sitting my son is smaller than him my
son is younger than him
and he's p and his dad is the coach and
he's sitting the bench
he comes up to my son he says you suck
at hitting and you're dumb and my son
said you're dumb for saying that i asked
him exactly what he said
and dean smacked my son in the face well
brody comes out my son's brody brody
comes out of the dugout
with a tear in his eye and his face red
i said what happened
he said dean just smacked me and listen
if you're a parent you know exactly what
happened the the hair on the back of my
neck stood up and i wanted to go
kick a 10 year old's ass i'd just be
honest like i wanted to go in there and
choke him and say did you lay a hand
on my son i did walk up to him and i
said i wanted to know if it was
i said did you just hit my son and he
didn't say that i said did you
just hit my son he said yes
i said okay i said go apologize to him
that's all i said i went up and talked
to his mom i was furious i was shaking
on the inside
because i know what my emotions wanted
to do i knew it was right so why am i
telling you this whole story
how's it related to you i promise you it
does
i went home that night and i was so mad
so upset and but i had the chance to
teach a lesson to brody
and i hated the feeling i had i was mad
at mike who's the greatest guy in the
world the greatest dad his son's going
through something somebody's probably
picking on dean
and we found out that's true so i sat i
originally
i i emailed mike i said mike you're a
great coach we love your family
but it's unacceptable that your son put
your his hand on my son
it's been six months i've been trying to
get bro to stand up for himself
uh brodie'll play the all-star game and
then we're out we're done
mike replied back as a good the good man
he is and said i'm embarrassed as a
coach and i failed as a father
i should have seen this i should have
known i wish i knew sooner
and he dug in and he got it so why am i
telling you
because that night i sat with my son and
i didn't like the way it felt to have
anger i didn't like the way it felt to
be mad and i said
buddy the greatest word i know i wish i
knew it sooner is forgiveness
dean's been a good kid mike's an amazing
dad what if we just forgave them
what if we gave them a second chance
what if
if if you want to forgive them i'd like
you to stay on the team but it's totally
up to you he goes no mike's been good to
me i want to stay on the team let's
forgive them
kind of paraphrasing our conversation so
i i email mike
we go back to the practice mike the
coach walks up to me with his head down
literally with a tear in his eye
and he said your son and i'm not saying
this because my boy
but he said yours my son's the sweetest
boy you've ever met in your life sweet
voice he's not aggressive
he might not make it in high school
baseball because he's so not aggressive
he's sweet
he's just kind and mike says to me i'm
not just saying this
your son is my favorite kid i've coached
in 10 years
your son is the reason i coach i love
that kid my son writes
the coach thank you notes that's my son
he busts my chops sometimes but he's
amazing everybody else so mike comes up
and i said mike
how about this it's it's past it's
behind us hopefully my
dean can learn from it we appreciate
everything you've done
and uh we really love you guys thank you
and let's move on from here
let's get to practice and he had a tear
in his eye and he was like
i don't understand if if that was my son
and someone did that to my son i
couldn't even look at me i'd want to
fight me
he's like i wish i could let go of
things like that because i probably
pulled this hat off because i'm probably
bold because i worry about all the stuff
people have done to me
i said i promise you i'm not just saying
that that's our family we're done
i'm forgiveness has happened brody
brody goes out i could cry now i could
have tears of mine brody goes out
and grabs dean and says hey let's play
catch i look out these two
dean is so sorry that he's out there
playing with brodie said good catch
brody i'm
so awesome bro i can't wait to watch you
hit today brody you're gonna crush it
today brody
my my son was smiling from ear to ear
mike
wipes the tears from his eyes shakes my
hand he's like you're a good man
you're a good man i'm like i'm not a
good man just something simple
forgiveness
it's gone for me it's gone for my son he
looked
he learned the lesson of a lifetime my
dad couldn't have forgiveness my dad his
father
abused him he took advantage of him his
family abused him so he never forgave
anybody and he lived with anger his
whole life that's probably why i'm the
opposite
so how does that relate to you why am i
doing
this training on forgiveness because if
you have somebody in your life who took
advantage of you i'm sorry someone who
cheated stole from you
lied to you ruined something ruined a
partnership caused you to go bankrupt
caused you to lose a job
it sucks but guess what if you haven't
forgiven them it's only hurting you
because there's so much
only so much time effort and energy in a
day and if you're using that
even with a fraction of what went wrong
why they did it whose fault is
then you don't have enough to compete in
today's world
this is a competitive world you need all
your energy
all your juices all your focus all your
enthusiasm focused on where you want to
go not something somebody did to you
you can't undo it so you might as well
forgive
if i was going to if you were to start a
business tomorrow i would say
what you should do above everything else
is find the closest competition that's
successful
even if it's not the exact product
something similar and stock them
stock every bit of their marketing over
everything else
i mean every detail don't just look and
say oh they're using blue and logos no
look at the wording look at the
messaging why are they getting people to
take action what does their first
website look like their opt-in page
what is their registration page if
they're an online business what is their
follow through
what does the sales video sound like
look like what does it
talk about what are the keywords what
are the headlines if you get an
email from the company what's the
subject line what's written in the email
what does the link
look like and then i would order the
product do what entrepreneurs do best
cut a check for speed order the product
order the similar product or something
in the same genre
how does the product get there what are
the shipping options how long does it
take to arrive when it arrives do you
get an email
and what's the email say does it offer
you additional products when you order
the products
does it offer you additional products at
a discount or additional services that
you can help with
when the product gets there dissect it
pull it apart then as far as product
goes how can you improve upon the
improve upon the product how can you put
a unique twist on it how can you go
upstream and make it one step better
disqualifying the competition
making yours the universal piece
what i'm saying is most people focus on
the products the colors the look the
feel
ask opinions most of your energy has to
be obsessed on the marketing to get
people to want what it is so you can
serve them
yes make your product the best on the
planet but once you do
your product your service your idea your
company the houses you sell whatever it
is you want to do
make sure it's the best but once it's
the best your obsession
has to be on marketing marketing and
sales are the oxygen for every
successful business
but people will spend 90 of their energy
on the completely wrong things go oh
i'm just going to put it out there and
if i build it they will come if i put it
for sale they'll take it
that's simply not true that's field of
dreams that's a movie with kevin costner
if you build it they will come they
won't come
they will never come you focus on
marketing read books on marketing read
books on copywriting
find competitors that aren't even in
they're not competitors they're not even
the same genre as you but they're
killing it online or killing it
with their retail store and see what
they're doing see how they treat their
customers
see how their customer service sounds
guys if you want your own business to
thrive or you want to start your own
business you got to throw away most
everything you're taught because they're
all wrong
what is it 70 of all businesses fail
within the first five years this is why
the focus is wrong listen are there
outliers where you build it and they
come yes
that's one in a million and there's
another gazillion people trying working
their asses off and i'm not saying it's
it's laziness sometimes it's the hardest
work ever
but if it doesn't sell if people don't
buy it people don't talk about if people
don't refer it
then it's just a really great idea
credit card parenting i don't know if
you've ever heard that
phrase before means pay now or pay later
i don't know if you ever heard the old
indian proverb that a man with his
health
has a thousand wishes and one without
has but one
i want to really emphasize the
importance of
keeping yourself healthy exercising
eating right now
you might say wow what has this got to
do with success it has everything to do
with success because here's what i know
if you don't
pay now like the credit card parenting
if you don't take care of yourself now
if you put off until tomorrow that
you're going to start eating better or
start
moving or start exercising it compounds
and it's that much harder not only to
get in shape but it's hard to reverse it
i mean listen if you could fast forward
your 75 year old self
and you knew you were visiting the
hospital on a weekly basis you were sick
you had a disease you had diabetes you
weren't as healthy as you could be you'd
do anything in your power
to change that today most people are
wrong that are giving you advice
the other thing i'll say is the most
costly advice in the world is bad advice
it's your broke friend telling you how
to get make money it's your
single friend telling you how to fix
your relationship stop listening all the
crap
listen to the good stuff like what
you're hearing here and other wonderful
people who have done it
and get rid of the stuff you shouldn't
be doing and stare at your destination
like an obsession think about how many
times in your life you had a massive win
because you had no confidence it doesn't
exist right
if you were looking to go meet that girl
or that guy and you walked up you're
like
hey um you know i was hoping we could
can i get your no that doesn't work you
walk in a business meeting
hey do you think we could no that
doesn't work go to talk to your kids
about something in school
hey kids uh no you need confidence you
need the energy you need to be alive
well if you know me i've been watching
my videos that's me i've made my career
on enthusiasm and energy and being in
the right state of mind having the
confidence
but you don't the biggest myth is that
you're born with confidence no
i was the shyest kid in the world i felt
so insecure
felt dumb i learned how to manufacture
the confidence
and after 25 years of being an
entrepreneur generating hundreds of
millions of dollars being blessed to
touch the lives of millions of people
around the world what i know for a fact
is that you can create the state of mind
and the confidence
to live the best you to unlock that
inner hero i
literally flew to arizona to meet a
media buyer and i said i have no idea
what i'm doing and i just kept pushing
in
and one of those things that i think
during the evolution of growing from
wherever you are to where you want to go
is do whatever you do best i mean do
whatever you're doing
the best you can knowing there's the
bigger horizon
so i literally was working during the
day on cars i was
i'd paint cars i was doing a collision
repair at night i'd go work on my
apartments and i was a plumber and
and and hung sheetrock and i'd worked
till midnight on houses and i was tired
but i had a dream i knew i wanted to
help people
do better so it made what i was doing
okay
because i knew there was more so the big
problem i see is people
want more and they hate what they're
doing so that if they're they're in a
they're in a state of mind where god i
just when i'm done with this crap then
someday i'll reach my dreams
and if you can flop that to go no this
is the gateway to my dreams i don't care
that i'm serving coffee or i'm painting
cars or i'm a teacher right now or i'm
on my sister's couch like this is what i
have to do and i have to do it the best
become a master at it just become a
master at that because and that's the
income
and the security and the mindset that
fuels the next level
it's not this is miserable i hate it i
feel the next level and now i'm amazing
it's like
you need to master that how can you find
the time the energy the effort
and the nerve to start to make that
first call
to put out that first bandit sign to put
up a craigslist they have to start to 25
to one
to call banks how do you do that well
this one today is learning to say no
now one thing i've learned from the most
successful people on the planet if you
want to say millionaires i've been lucky
enough to meet billionaires
the one thing i've learned the more they
say no
the wealthier they get now you may have
heard me say this before but it's that
important
of a success principle it took you a lot
of yeses to get here
yes to overtime yes to missing your kids
you know soccer or
dance class yes to your wife your
husband getting upset because you're
working later yes to
getting my program yes to going to a
live event yes to getting the education
yes yes yes yes to your friends you know
you if you're watching this you are the
busiest people other people know
they say if you want something done ask
somebody busy because they know how to
get things done that's you
you're the person in your family amongst
your friends i know it or else you
wouldn't be watching me that could ask
for emotional support
financial support for a ride for help
for advice
so you are used to saying yes so this
week
i want you to say no i want you to make
a list of the things that you
must say no to so you can focus on you
so you can make a massive impact for
your family you want to help family
members that need money
say no to them for a year become an
incredible real estate investor
and then if you want to cut them checks
you can if you want to give more to your
church
you want to give more to charity say no
for a little while to so many things so
your brain is not all over the place
we think we have add most of us don't
have add there's just too much coming at
us
and we say yes to too many things so
here's the assignment
what can you figure out to say no to
this week because if you say
no to things that don't improve your
life don't improve your family's life
don't
possibly increase your future income or
put you on a path to the goals that you
have to spend more time with your family
to get out of a job you hate to pay off
bills i don't know what they are
but you have to make a not a to-do list
but you have to make a list of what
not to do who are you going to say no to
who are you going to disappoint
what are you going to let go what habits
are eating up your time
kaizen the study of kaizen is one
step one little piece at a time that's
how do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time how do you win
or run a thousand mile race one step at
a time when japan rebuilt
after world war ii they had to adapt
kaizen because everything was destroyed
they looked at everything gone they
couldn't imagine trying to rebuild japan
but what did they do they rebuilt it
one brick at a time one person at a time
one business at a time and it
turned into such a thriving country so
fast because they adopted kaizen break
it up into small pieces you got a goal
take a bite today this moment when
you're done watching us right now go do
something towards your goal
go send an email call somebody say no
say yes
look for a new job start the company
just create the url
real quick i think there's three types
of entrepreneurs there's an entrepreneur
who wants to work under the blanket of
someone else
right they're the company they're the
person that's in a company like man that
guy that woman
she just they want to rise up through
the ranks and be an entrepreneur
but kind of with the safety net and it
doesn't make them better or worse than
anybody
i mean without the implementers in your
life without the team who would i be
without the amazing people on my team
secondly
there's lifestyle entrepreneurs like my
buddy dean jackson he's got this i know
i'm being successful when list this is
for anybody's got a lifestyle
entrepreneur there's just a certain
amount of money he says
i know i'm being successful when i don't
i don't have an alarm clock in my house
and it never goes off
i wear black t-shirts every day and no
one gives a [ __ ]
um i golf you know i golf at least five
times a week
i live on a 50 000 a month net income
i live like what do you say i live like
an artist with a trust fund except i
don't know how to paint
so he's got this he's so he like he has
this list he knows he's being successful
when
and that's that's a lifestyle
entrepreneur and then there's
entrepreneurs that just want to keep
that just want
their accomplishment based it has
nothing to do with the money they
thought it was
and i think this would mean they thought
it was when i get the money and success
out of the way that i could stop
worrying
and it's not it's the next
accomplishment well can you do this but
it's
yeah it's it's the game and i think it
converts that's why you see somebody
like richard branson that
that his whole life now is uh virgin
unite you know his charity i i spent a
couple weeks with him out in his island
because
me and joe polish raised a million bucks
for him so we got to spend time with him
and he started that same process made
all the money and then now he's still
driven but now it's how many more
schools he could build in africa
so it never changes it just but always
have your focus on something like
you see people who go to you know warren
buffett
his age he's still crushing because he
has a bigger purpose we always have to
have that so
i would say yeah i you know a couple
years ago especially when the kids are
young i was thinking of
should i just cash out and spend 10
years being dad but i would i wouldn't
be the best me i love accomplishing i
love creating i love something new
uh you know so did you ever have
something where
it immediately boiled your blood
immediately made you
made you feel pissed like like anger or
adrenaline rushed through not in a good
way not positive adrenaline
a lot of times that happens when you
know someone took advantage of you
you know sometimes that happens when
people lie to you like blatantly lie to
you
or someone causes something when you
knew
it was gonna happen like please don't do
that please don't do that
they do it and it breaks or it changes
or the relationship is over the business
doesn't work
or someone robs money from you i don't
know maybe you're thinking right now
maybe somebody took advantage of you by
being unfaithful in the relationship
yeah this is millionaire success habits
podcast
but all of these things lead to a
successful life
and that's why i want to share each and
every one of you
each and every one of you i want to
share this with because we got to get it
like this stuff's got to stick to us
we don't get this by reading one book or
what listening to one podcast or
watching one video
we got to live this for lack of a better
word we gotta stop screwing around
we gotta implement this and be a part of
our life so the reason i'm sharing this
this morning
i bought a piece of property 20
something years ago i'll just tell you
the story at 30 000 feet so i buy this
property 20
probably 20 i don't know 24 years ago 26
years ago
crazy long time ago i bought it with
someone and since then
they kind of bailed out little piece of
property not millions of dollars smaller
piece of property but
anyway long story short they bailed out
don't pay the taxes don't pay the
insurance and then the
so i've been paying it for years um
now this has been 20 something years the
property's been sitting there and i just
had it for too long it's time to just
i'm gonna unload it and sell it to a
friend
at a huge discount about a third of what
i've paid for the taxes over the year
and the insurance on the property right
so i reach out to the uh half
owner and all i said was hey you know
what we got this property
i'm selling it to a friend just so i
have to pay the taxes on it if you want
it you can surely have it take over the
taxes
um but i'm just gonna dump it so could
you sign off on it
no reply no reply finally i get a reply
this morning
it's like well how much could i get out
of it what kind of money can i get
and after all these years of not saying
anything
and all these years of other
circumstances where i went above and
beyond for this person years and years
ago to help out
that's what i got now i'm literally in
my car
before i go and i'm looking at text
messages just moments ago
and i got furious like it hit me like
maybe it's
old feelings like maybe being picked on
when i was little because i was small or
or you know just something hit my
ego something hit my brain i was pissed
i'm like
i wanted to reply back like what the f f
do you mean like all that i've done
paid all the taxes all the other things
all i'm asking is to stop the bleeding
or you could even have the property if
you want it
and that's the reply get not hey thanks
for covering the taxes and insurance for
all those years sorry i haven't brought
anything up
sorry i didn't contribute but guess what
here's what i realized i got mad for
probably
that that something like that could have
made me mad 20 years ago for
a week i could have bitched about it i
could have told my friends about it i
said oh you don't believe what's
happening to me
so my first reply was a bit snarky like
not super sarcastic i'm like well then
i'm done you could have it i take the
property i'll sign it off to you
and i was i almost sent another one like
what the f man like why would you and
then i thought about it
and i said the only person that's
hurting is me
i'm gonna film a bunch of videos today
i'm at my studio i just pulled in my
office i'm at my studio
it's 8 24 am as i'm recording this for
you
and i'm gonna go in and film videos for
three hours on a training that i
freaking love it's gonna be so awesome
you guys
i'll get access to it you'll see it and
some new podcasts
if i let that bug me that's gonna screw
up how i effect
positively affect you if i let that bug
me it's going to throw my day off
if i let that bug me i'm going to not be
the same dad to my kids when they come
home from school today
i'm not going to be the same person it's
going to throw me off guess what
the other person nothing's going to
change for them
the only person that's going to
negatively impact by me getting pissed
is me
because can i make them act a different
way am i am i in charge of their
emotions am i in charge of the way they
feel
and i thought maybe they're going
through something maybe they're
financially strapped maybe they're
fighting with their spouse or
their loved ones and and i just sat this
all happened literally in moments i'm
sitting in the car ready to send a wise
ass
remark reply and i said if i send this
only person is hurting me i'm going to
be off today i won't shoot my videos
i'll start thinking why would they do
this to me i'm such a good guy in this
situation i went over and above
and and people take advantage of me then
i'll start thinking who else has taken
advantage of me and who else just
screwed me over and
why is that happening and is my
accountant doing the right job is my
secretary doing a good job that's the
path we can go down
am i perfect no i screw this all
the time but i just sat and i sat
i erased the reply i was gonna send and
i sent one back
and said okay no worries i'll handle it
um
i hope things are well with you have a
great day and best wishes on all you do
and i sent it and it was done
it was it was literally done the the
the anger i felt the didn't take an
advantage feeling i had
it was all done it was out and it was
gone and
let me ask you what are you holding on
to right now
that's hindering your success you want
millionaire success habits
let go of the stuff that's holding you
back let go of the stuff
that builds resentment let go of the
stuff that allows you not to trust
anybody
like go with the stuff that's stopping
you from great relationships like go
with the stuff that's stopping you from
having a partnership
let go of the stuff that keeps you
afraid of going on and venturing out to
do your own thing
it's only hurting you the only reason
you think about money is because there's
not enough flowing into your life
because when money flows into your life
you get to be your best you
and the only reason i'm sharing that is
because so many people have this deep
seated
fear of making extra money listen if you
can cut a check for a problem
you don't have that damn problem anymore
you worry about your kids you can cut a
check worrying about credit card bills
worrying about your business wondering
about your parents
if you can kind of check for that
problem does it solve the problem we
still have to work on us it doesn't fix
us but it solves a lot of problems
so when i ask you why you want to make
more money why you want to diversify why
you want to have a new stream of income
i just want to give you this little
example i hired a consultant to help me
be better with my students get more
people engaged to take action
he said to me sits down for two minutes
he goes well did you ever teach him the
seven levels deep of why they're doing
it
i said no but if it helps him give it to
me he's like no you only have to go you
have to go through it or else i won't
give it to you
i said fine i'll go through it so the
whole thing is i'm gonna get wrap this
up quick
is whatever answer you said when i said
why do you want to make more money
ask the same question again with that
answer so my first question my first
answer was
i want to have an incredible company
that changes the world
while i make great money and can help
other people that was my first house
sounds noble right sounds like that's
all from the brain that's solid that's
who we are we got this company we're
going to change the world
but then he said to me dean why is that
important
for you with my answer why is it
important for you to have a solid
business to help change lives to make
the money
and i gave another message from my from
my head of you know well i i want to i
want to set the standard in my industry
and get rid of all the crap and i did
about four or five answers so i want you
to do this tonight go through this seven
times
but what happens around the fourth time
you ask yourself that question
you flop from your head to your heart
so i got to the third one and i said i
never want to go backwards
don't even know where it came from you
know as a kid my we were broke as
crap i mean we might wore hand-me-downs
i got dropped off far from school so the
kids wouldn't make fun of my
mom's junky car i was homeless at one
point with my parents we had no place to
go i'd i'd lie and tell my friends i had
no money at school
i tell them that you know i didn't feel
like eating because my mom didn't have
the buck so i could eat that day
now that's not poor me this that shaped
me i love every bit of it
but i hated it and i realized i didn't
want to go backwards
he said i said that's it and he said to
me no dean we're not done it's not it's
seven levels deep not five
so why don't you want to go backwards
and it just hit me and i remember i got
emotional i got goosebumps i said i
never want my kids to experience what i
went through i don't want to raise
entitled kids
but i want them to have options i'm like
that's it i'm done he's like no there's
one more
like what there could be and it just hit
me i said i want to be in control of my
life
my parents got married five times each
if you're military you moved a lot you
know what it's like every time you have
friends family new school
you got to move i moved 20 times by the
time i was 19 and i just realized at
that very moment
i wanted to be in control of my life i
wanted to dress the way i want i want to
do the work i wanted to work i wanted to
raise my kids the way i wanted
no one was going to tell me what to do
in my adult life and that was my why
if you're having a tough day your
business is kicking your ass and you
just think you want emotional
or financial support or financial
freedom it's not enough to get through a
tough day
but when you know your true why i went
on stage for years doing this week after
week
and i'd get a woman come up a woman
yesterday said she wanted to make money
to travel the world
i reminded me of a woman came up her
first why was i want to travel the world
after seven levels deep she got to
number one you know what she said
she goes my physically abusive husband
left me two years ago
on the way out the door he said you're a
pathetic loser you'll never amount to
anything and she goes i'm going to show
him wrong
screw him that was her why
is that a stronger why than just wanting
to travel the world
i had another guy stand up and he said i
want to change the youth
in my neighborhood there's not a lot of
dads no support i want to create this
company i've already started making
money i'm going to take it to a next
level
what a strong why coming from his head
you know what his number one was
that his mom died before she knew that
he said good
she set a good example and he felt he
showed her he was a loser while she was
alive and he was going to show her he
was a winner in her death
i'm talking about these two and i've
been blessed to meet presidents multiple
presidents i've met billionaires i've
been lucky to meet a lot of people and i
feel honored and blessed
but all of them have a kind of a
humbleness
of felt they weren't ready
and not as good as you perceive them
okay i'll give you an example derek said
he went to
england to study and about
four weeks before the world championship
his coach came to him and said
get ready in two weeks you're doing a
competition if you
win that and qualify you're going to the
world championship and he said
i'm not ready four weeks i'm not ready
he thought he was going the year
after and she said you're ready for it
he said he pined over and said
no way i'm not ready and she told him
and the cool part is she
he had a good mentor he had someone that
became like a second mom to him who told
him
yes you're ready yes you're ready he
went to that event two weeks in
he won that he qualified for the world
championship and then he's like
i qualified there but this is the world
everybody from the world is coming in
i can't do this i'm too young he started
going through all these excuses
and then like all entrepreneurs do it so
i want you to know we all think the same
things you do
and all the things that are there are
there for everybody
but one difference is overcome your fear
and step it up
and jump in the game because listen you
know wayne gretzky said you miss a
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take
he wanted to wait a whole another year
when they when he went into the
competition
they had him ranked that he would finish
fifth through seventh
and he jumped in he did the performances
of his life and he won the world
championship
feeling he wasn't ready completely
didn't want to do it i mean
think about his how his life probably
changed forever
forever and ever because he actually
overcame that fear
didn't listen to that demon those voices
inside telling he wasn't ready
and he got in the game and i want you to
think about
future proofing your life what does that
mean
you know technology is moving so fast
right now i was just an event last week
with peter diamantis the
author of abundance he's the creator of
the x prize he was the one that put up
the money
for the first uh ship that went into
orbit that wasn't part of nasa or part
of a government
like the guy is just unbelievably such a
visionary and showed where we're going
you know right now there's a hundred
cars in pittsburgh ubers that are
driving themselves they're driverless
cars
ford is making driverless cars they're
thinking that uber alone
in six or seven years will be 100
driverless that's there's a million uber
drivers
technology right now robots are going to
be cleaning our house not in a hundred
years like
in 10 robots are taking over factories
so what that means is
a lot of jobs are going to be lost a lot
of scarcity a lot of people getting
scared
uncertain times but really
the foundation of all success isn't the
magic widget the magic pill that gets
you rich the lucky invention
all success starts with our habits all
successful people
don't they don't worry about the change
they embrace it they want it peter
diamantis is on stage and say do you see
how this
amazingness is but what you have to
think about is how do you future proof
your life
how do you future proof your income what
are some of the things that you can do
to make sure you're in a job that's
sustainable your you create a business
that's sustainable
all of those are kind of to me abundant
they're everywhere but what happens is
when you back up five or six steps
that's where it all starts it all starts
with an abundant mindset
it all starts with having a vision and
clarity of what you really want out of
your life
it all starts with not working on your
weaknesses and gaining your confidence
it all starts with knowing why you want
more and it starts with having the
habits
that make you not overcome but thrive
during these uncertain times
stop worrying about technology stop
worrying
about the crazy politicians in today's
world
stop letting the news affect you stop
letting the outside world control your
knobs turn you up turn you down you can
future proof your life
by not letting those thoughts that the
future is bad
live inside your head if we focus on
what could go wrong if we focus on
robots and technology taking our job we
get small
what i want you to start doing is think
how you can go big to how you can
open up and say what is this amazing
technology a billion people going to be
coming online over the next 10 years
all these changes this amazing
technology how can you step out in front
of it
how can you be a part of something
people will always need
how can you look at it through glasses
where it's half full
where you can look it through look at it
through an abundance
state rather than a scarcity state
listen life is going to happen
anyway technology is going to happen
anyway we can focus on what's wrong with
it or how can it hurt us
and that's how we feel that's how we act
and that's what we get or we can find a
way to find
abundance out of it find joy out of it
find excitement about the future
and with that you will find the path
that will create
wealth will create joy if you're one of
my real estate students everybody will
always need real estate
if you're not in real estate whatever it
is you do find the angle if you're in
the life coaching business
everybody will always need life coaching
high performance coaching
that's two of a million things you could
be doing that are future proof
but the biggest thing i want to share
today what really future proof
future proofing your life means is
having the right state of mind
being the observer of your thoughts and
find a way to focus on the future
not dragging that anchor of your past
behind you what stands between
us and where we want to go is
never what we think it is it's not the
economy it's not the president it's not
that somebody already dominated the
health food industry or dominated
facebook advertising or dominated tv
advertising or there's no room left
it's never that it's always the story we
tell ourselves and why we can't
achieve that and and if if i want to
boil it down i would just say
what is your biggest why what's your
biggest goal that you would love if it
was a year from now we were sitting here
you're watching this it was a year later
and it was the best year of your life
what would be the biggest thing that
would have changed in your life
from money income family love intimacy
being a better dad mom whatever whatever
that is
if you say to yourself i would love that
goal like i i'd love
to have my company doing a million
dollars a year in net profit so it could
have freedom for my family
then just say but and whatever that butt
is is usually your story it's like i
would love my company to be doing a
million dollars yet but i live in a
smaller town and there's just not enough
people to do it or
the internet's so saturated there's no
room to advertise on facebook anymore
cause everybody their brother's on
whatever that story is is usually your
story and that's the result you get and
that story is the the thing the thing
standing between you and your next level
and and i know people are watching right
now going oh dean that's nice you guys
got money now so it's easy i don't have
any money
i don't have a partner i don't have any
business experience
you know this economy is not right for
what we do
and and you know where there's where
there's you know that old saying where
there's a will there's a way
if that if your story is that that's
what you'll continue to get so
what i would say is if i was gonna boil
it down
is find what that story is
now to you you might be saying dean
you're saying it's a belief it's reality
and maybe it's phase three but reality
is nothing more than our perception of a
situation right we all know that you've
read that about you've watched it on
tom's show
everybody has said it but maybe it's the
first time you actually think about it
that
that reality you think is holding you
back is really just the story
so there's two things i say is go find
somebody else with that same story
like go look at your your your evolution
where you were
on your couch no money right go look at
richard branson's story look at tony
robbins story look at
you know john paul digiorio or all the
amazing books everybody i've read every
book in there that's amazing the people
you've got to interview and meet
but read all those stories and realize
that first of all that story you have is
probably a lie
right so if you can find proof like
leverage that it's a lie that's one
thing but then
the one that would get me is i love
aspiration
i love to look and say look what you did
man i i want to get there if he did it i
can do it
but sometimes you need the pain as well
so what i like to do is i like to think
take that story and think it's five
years from now and think it's 10 years
from now
and you're still in the same exact spot
you are now you're still worried you
still have envy you still
want more you desire more you want to
take care of your family you want to
provide more
and think that that story those two
sentences
is the thing holding you back do you
really want to give that story that much
power and then think it's ten years from
now and that story is still done and all
of a sudden
it like for me i think am i gonna let
that story stop me i brought my son with
me today am i gonna stop from giving him
the opportunities that i didn't i'm not
raising i have two children i'm not
raising entitled kids i want to give
massive opportunity
i don't want to leave him a trust fund
i'm going to leave him massive
opportunity and train him
i'm not going to let any story get in
the way of me being that dad and if a
story pops up
that says hey i can't make baseball this
week because of this i'll change a damn
story i'll fist fight with that story
and i'll look at the pain i'll have if i
keep that story so
i love the aspirational part of this
story will stop me from my new life but
also like
are you let that story screw you around
for the next five 10 15 years i mean
man we're we're going to be 90 laying in
a bed looking up
like before we know it and you want to
think i squeezed all i could out of life
or did i let just beliefs that other
people gave me hold me back
i love this phrase i've been saying for
about six months success tax
yeah earlier you know what i love about
that somebody told to me i didn't make
it up but i found my own version of it
it's like we all want to make more money
we all want to
feel significance abundance freedom
but most people aren't willing to pay it
so a great analogy i've been using is
if you're in a band and you play the
guitar and you write songs it would be
amazing to be at madison square garden
50 000 people
singing your song you're out in the
front of the stage i mean could anything
be more euphoric right
but everybody would want that but who's
willing to play the guitar when no one's
watching until your hands hurt
who's willing to pack up an old van that
barely runs and drive to dive bar after
dive bar playing where people are booing
you
most people aren't willing to put in the
success tax to pay
and i said i said what if you just
visualized whether you believe in god
whatever you believe in
that there's an auditor a success
auditor and you go okay ed
ed started lives in a ghetto okay but
he's still positive every day wow he's
still respectful wow he tried that first
business and his first partner screwed
him over took all the money and left
wow he still got up the next day still
inspiring other people still not a jerk
check check what if you got to check off
ten boxes
before you get to the other side because
once you get to the other side it opens
up like ed's amazing backyard there's
not many people playing at that level
like everybody thinks it's so
competitive up here it's not because you
guys are all fighting over crumbs and i
don't mean that disrespectfully
but all i'm saying is when you said like
put in the success tax and know you're
going to fail know it's going to go
sideways
but it's worth it most of the time in
our life and i hate to say this and
maybe you've heard this before maybe you
know it to be true and if it's first
time you're hearing i'm sorry to be the
one to share it with you
most of the time our next level of life
lives on the other side of our biggest
obstacle the thing we worry about the
thing we stress about
usually is the the little wall
that once we get past it through it
break a hole and the other side is our
next level
so with that in mind think about that
think of your next level of life your
income your business your
your success right you're on the
millionaire success habits podcast
that means you want another level of
income life wealth abundance joy right
that's why you're here
you'll be doing a million other things
you're with me and i don't i don't take
it lightly that's why i want to deliver
value
but if you're here that means what you
want you want that next level
well if it lives on the other side of
the wall that's in front of you the
obstacle it's in front of you
if you have a plan b in some cases that
means you didn't burn the boat so you
want to take the island
burn the boats so there's no other
choice but for tape but
for taking the island if you want to
accomplish that a conqueror or
accomplish that next level of life goal
abundance start that business take your
new
your current business next level finally
stop listening to all the naysayers tell
your parents they're crazy your friends
they're crazy all this
the bs that we have in life if you want
to do it a plan b
will screw you up because you go well if
it doesn't work i can go back when you
get to the wall and you start trying to
climb it
i'm saying this wall is the obstacle
between you and your next level of life
obviously it's a metaphor but if you get
to the wall and you get a little scratch
on your hand you can go
i can go to plan b ah the boats are
still in the harbor maybe they've taken
this island's a little too much no
what i want to shock you into thinking
about today is
if you've been dabbling for so long if
you've been desiring a next level any
area in your life
yeah this is the millionaire success
habits podcast but any area of your life
that you're not having the breakthroughs
you're not having the success you want
the next level you want
that means most likely you have a
comfortable plan
b that's good enough when you want to
accomplish something big
something out of your comfort zone that
next level that you've been craving
then screw plan b make everything all of
your energy plan
a burn the boats knock the wall down go
through the pain go through
whatever it takes and put all the focus
is like no
there's no plan b this is this is my
life
i don't think we should drive for money
i think we should drive to be a better
version of ourselves
when money was no longer a worry for me
i dove into me
and i have been ignoring and tucking
down a lot of crap for a lot of years
and i was surface level i looked like
the guy that had it all going on my
businesses were doing good i have
amazing children
company thriving i live in the right
neighborhood drive the right
have the right friends everything looked
great
but it was all masked and when money got
out of the way
i was able to find dig into me and do my
own personal development and my own
personal growth
and really find the things that i wanted
to fix so i could become a better
version because
i know if i'm pointing because my son's
over there it doesn't matter what i tell
him
as a parent and if you're a parent you
know what i'm talking about i could
teach him everything i give him lessons
we do sunday meetings
i can teach him lessons every he's going
to become
who i am not what i say and i'm going to
lead by example and i want to be a
better version of me
and money's allowed that money has not
made me
uh evil or done bad things it's
it's allowed me to not worry about that
part so i could focus on me and
simultaneously the more i focused on me
the more i wanted to take my money and
do better for other people
i mean i heard somebody say once when
they said they think money's evil they
said you haven't made enough and you
haven't given enough away yet
i'm trying to be the most authentic
version of myself that exists
like i don't ever want somebody and you
know this too how many times because
you've had amazing guests dude
the lineup you've had is incredible but
every once in a while
it's not so good to meet your heroes and
i don't mean like you exactly and it's
not that
your hero and you idolize them you're
like man that guy's a badass or that
woman she's incredible
and then you're in the kitchen with him
for 10 minutes like wow
like i don't ever want that i want
someone to say i saw dean on video and
then i met him
and then i saw him in a tight situation
and i saw him with his kids all the same
guy
yeah and i think that's where life like
that's i i just want to be the same guy
in all areas and i think
even though i'm working on myself it
comes through on video and my sales glow
for me confidence is i just look at
things again in the simplest form i've
never done anything good in my life when
my confidence was down
i never got the girl when i was young i
never closed the deal
i didn't get the money i wanted i didn't
get the partnership and not
not like your confidence is in the
toilet and you're pathetic with your
shoulders down i'm talking about your
confidence is five percent off yeah do
you ever go into a meeting and you know
you're a little off and you're like i'm
gonna i'm just gonna grip my way through
it you come out like damn i should have
just either ignored it or took a moment
to build my confidence because i didn't
get what i wanted
and i've just been obsessing on knowing
that my confidence needs to be high at
all times
so there's a million different ways to
go i love what ed said on how to build
confidence
keeping the promises you make with
yourself incredible one of the things i
do is i really obsess on looking at the
things that take my confidence
so for me as simple as this sounds is
i haven't watched the news in 10 years i
don't watch it all
because i've never watched the news and
got down and go wow
i feel amazing like you don't watch the
news go ahead hey man i watched the news
this morning dude you got you should
catch it at 12.
you're not gonna believe it you're not
gonna believe how amazing [ __ ] is no
you're watching news you're like
oh my god right so the news um i know
this sounds crazy and we know this is
simple but i've really eliminated the
people in my life and you've heard this
a million times that
robbed my confidence and i've either
became if they're family members i put
the teflon up
or i've slowly pushed them out of my
life and
any exercise anything that i do that
robs my confidence the people i surround
myself
exercises like i said don't work on your
weaknesses i've obsessed on not to-do
lists
so if i go hey when i do xyz it robs my
confidence i don't like it i know it's
got to go out of my life like my
my threshold confidence builder
confidence detractor if it's a detractor
it goes on the thing that's got to go
away so
i would just encourage you think about
the things the people the events you do
the
going to happy hour with the guys from
work and all they do is complain about
how
your job or your boss is or your company
is if that makes you feel bad about
yourself then they're
they're robbing you of your bigger
future so i would say
one of the things besides what ed said
is make a list of the things that ding
your confidence just a little bit
and either reframe them or eliminate
them you know the movie fueled the
dreams with kevin costner it might be
before your time maybe you never saw it
but it was a whole concept of if you
build it they will come it was about
his father was a professional baseball
player
and he kept having these dreams these
visions and heard this voice of if you
build that they will come and he
he built this uh awesome baseball field
out in the middle of his farm
in a corn patch and and then all the
ghosts of
baseball past came and played amazing
movie
great inspirational but that's
unfortunately how most people feel about
their businesses
they feel if you build something good
enough
if you build the right or you find the
right widget and you create something
people
need that if it's so good or if you
write a book and it's so good or you
create a course and it's so good or if
you become a real estate investor
and you're so good if you build it they
will come and guess what they will
not come that's the biggest
misconception people have about business
what happens is there's some outliers
there's a book every couple of years
that just gets written and virally goes
nuts there's a video
that gets made and it goes viral and
everybody sees it there's a product
that's created
and you see it and you don't hear
anything behind the scenes you just
think they built it and people came
and that's not true you see if you don't
focus your energy in your business in
your
new side income in the thing that you
have passion for
if you don't focus on marketing and
sales
most likely you'll fail i don't know how
else to put it i'm just gonna put it the
way it is
people who don't obsess on marketing and
sales
fail here's what i know i
wanted to help change people's lives
through showing them how i made money in
cars and real estate my first
course to teach other people was called
motor millions because that's what i did
i hustled cars in my teens
my early 20s i'd match buyers and
sellers i'd fix wrecked cars and i
made a living in fact i got into real
estate
um while i was doing cars the cars were
paid my bills
and i started with no money so i wanted
to show people how to make money with
cars i created a course called motor
millions now that was
amazing and i just thought hey i'm going
to build this great course being naive
i'm going to build this great course
show people i did it and people are just
going to buy it
that wasn't the case i had to learn how
to market and that was tough
because it went against everything in
fact i used to think maybe marketing and
sales was a little like
a little sh absolutely not everything
you do
you're being marketed to everything you
do been sold to sales and marketing
are the oxygen of every successful
company remember that sales and
marketing are the oxygen
for every successful company and think
about it can you go without oxygen
heck no can a business go without
marketing sales heck no so then
i build my first real estate course to
teach people how to how i made money
with real estate
was called think a little different same
thing think a little different did
pretty good
it was a great course showed people how
to make money in real estate it's a
great course
but it wasn't a monster hit and and then
i started realizing
that what i was sharing with people the
benefits
of my course the the benefits of my
experience
the benefits of people not have to learn
through their own trial and error they
can learn
from my trial and error all of that was
there
but i was still doing okay several
million dollars in sales profits were
tiny
and then i realized what i was missing
is i needed to obsess on marketing and
sales i needed not to become a good
marketer
not good with sales i had to become
amazing at it
and something i just always loved saying
is because it really affected me when i
was young stop
trying to get good at the things you
suck at too i just i need to say that
because it's the biggest lie we've ever
been told it
brings our confidence with i still can't
read if i if i wrote you two sentences
in an email
half the words would light up misspelled
and some of them are so bad that
i try three different times to spell it
and the computer can't even
like if it could talk to me like idiots
like what are you trying to say
i have no freaking clue what you're
saying and then i just put like good
you know like i completely related so
but what it does is let me just ask you
watching or listening right now if
you're
if you work on something you suck at
does it make you feel empowered does it
make you feel like you want to like me
trying to do accounting like
you could never do it it's not my
personality so
what i know about the most successful
people on the planet including you ed
you just got
really great at a few things correct the
things that lights you up the things
that inspire you and when that
fire starts you can't stop it and
eventually you'll pay someone to do the
things you suck at maybe you can't
afford that now
but just don't don't let anybody give
you a bill of goods on
on working on the things try to get
better at what you're failing no just go
get great at a few things
yeah i wish i could debate you on that
but i can't because i 100 agree
i went to work with my dad in his
collision shop and i used to fix cars
every day i mean you wrecked your car i
fixed it i
i painted painted acrylics i i changed
engines i did breaks i was greasy every
day
you know what it was part of my journey
but then
in about let's see 19
i'd say 90-ish maybe no 90
no maybe 93 my dad went through a really
horrible divorce
his third divorce had hit him really bad
and he gave up on life gave up on his
business
he let the building where the collision
shop was he let it go
so i'm not paying rent didn't pay the
rent on his house and said i'm done by
house and he literally checked himself
into a place to get better and they
wouldn't let him out um so he's in there
for a while so now i'm i'm in my early
20s
uh i don't know the exact year i should
but i was in my early 20s
and um i had no place to go i had to get
out of the house i was living in he said
good luck
um so i rented his house for him so he
wouldn't lose it
um got some tenants in there got that
paying for itself so
that paid the mortgage but then i had to
move out of the collision shop my dad
had he rented it
so i found this barn it was on a piece
of property that where i was living i
was living in a tiny little apartment
that i moved into this tiny little
apartment
and i literally moved a compressor
a wood stove and all my tools into this
imagining this barn nothing big like you
know
barn doors barely fit two cars in and it
was
heading towards winter and i started
fixing cars out of there
literally i i asked
every friend i have if you wreck your
car i got this and then i i had enough
good will that i put out to the world
that i i got enough to eat like
i'd fix a car my attorney i fixed his
car
my my friend of a friend the guy i
worked out with at the gym's buddy and i
just
i kept hustling and pushing to get cars
uh to fix
working out of the most disgusting
garage in the world
feeling like a pathetic loser like
because when i didn't go to college i
remember thinking yeah but i have a
drive in me no one else has
i don't need college i can do this and
all of a sudden i'm in this dumpy little
barn with a bunch a couple lights in it
with a wood stove for heat some tools
by myself sucking fumes getting greasy
and i had days and maybe you've had days
like this i've had days where i was like
wow
i guess this is life for me you know
maybe success is meant for other people
maybe i
should have went to college maybe i wish
i came from a different family i wish i
was smart
all those things would happen on the
days sucking fumes putting wood in the
wood stove
greasy fingers but
here's what i remembered i remembered
those were just
every third day but i was lucky enough
to realize
that they were just thoughts i could
think that and i could end up struggling
like my dad
just being honest i love him i could
struggle like my mom struggle like the
rest of my family i remember thinking no
there's more for me this is just a
stepping stone i didn't realize it then
i was a kid
but i was paying success tax you might
be paying
success tax right now thinking it's the
worst thing in your world
life is screwed up you wish you had a
better break and you don't when you look
back someday
if you don't give up you'll realize that
you wouldn't take away those moments for
anything
listen me standing in front of this
garage
this garage where i was embarrassed and
didn't want to tell my friends and
and i was thinking everybody's like oh
mr big shot thought you were gonna make
it look at you now
oh working out of a garage yeah that's
that's what i
felt but now i look back that picture is
pride
this is my pride i worked out of this
garage sucking fumes grease under my
nails using a wood stove to get heat
using credit cards to get by begging
friends to to let me fix their cars
but guess what that built the grit that
built my muscle
that made me realize if i can go from
that place
to where i am now then what's next for
me
and i felt that way at every evolution
in my 20s my 30s my 40s this
decade i'll be in my 50s so what about
you
where are you currently paying success
tax and you're thinking it's the worst
thing in your life when actually it's
the path
designed for you you can't get to the
next level without dealing
with what you're dealing with right now
old analogy
it's been played out but if you spill a
glass of milk
you can really obsess on whose fault it
is why it's spelt
why it's spilled how it's gonna how it's
gonna you know smell
all those things or you can get a towel
clean it up and get a new glass of milk
where in your life are you looking
backwards where in your life are you
still
the victim and you could have been the
victim but is it helping you
where in your life are you stalled is it
money is it relationships is it your
health
where in your life are you looking
backwards where you can flip it right
now and just start saying how do i fix
it
how do i focus on a better outcome how
do i learn from those mistakes
revamp retool what i was doing and move
on you might have some
lingering from 10 years ago that you
need to just focus on solutions today
but this podcast is for something
different yes
fix the old stuff clean it up but i want
you to start programming your mind
framing everything in your mind start
looking something goes wrong
immediately go no no i'm not gonna go
how do i fix it what are some solutions
solution focused thinking is how
successful people get that way
winston churchill said the definition of
success is going from failure to failure
without losing your enthusiasm we are
going to fail
stuff's going to go sideways but those
who make it those that excel
are the ones and i've used this term
before paying success tax
by focusing on the solutions by learning
from their mistakes
by having their mistakes be the building
blocks to their success
not the anchor holding you down as
entrepreneurs it's like it's great when
you see when someone doesn't post an
entrepreneur it's like
oh my god this is amazing oh life sucks
i'm gonna go broke i'm losing everything
i should have never tried oh no wait
i found it things are good it's really
good i'm the greatest i can't make a
mistake oh my god i screwed up again
right that's the life of an entrepreneur
but i would choose it a million times
over
even with the failures but i have to
tell you so
um real estate education right so
real estate was my life that's what made
me a millionaire in my 20s i
wrote a book be a real estate
millionaire that book alone broke a
million
copies um and i wrote that book and
launched it in 2007 when the market was
crashing
everybody was doing it the same way i
taught people on the way down don't
fix and flip don't buy and hold we don't
know where the bottom is wholesale on
the way down so i taught a wholesale
strategy
book went on fire i don't know if any
other real estate book has ever sold a
million copies
we sold a million to that one um but
on that way down we built a company we
probably went from 2007 to 2000
maybe 12. in that downturn where all my
competitors literally they were all gone
by time we hit the bottom they were gone
and we were 100 million dollar your
company and making a massive impact and
i was working hard to get more influence
and all those things right so
companies growing while everybody else
is going down so anyway long story short
we became
i became the number one real estate
educator on the planet no one has ever
touched as many lives as we can
and i've held that title for a long time
but about four years ago
uh we were also in the live event space
doing amazing 60 70 live events a week
i wanted to go deeper because so many of
my students they can you can give
somebody a business
on how to sell 20 bills for 10 bucks and
they'll still screw it up
they'll find a way to find an obstacle
they'll find a way to tell them that my
family's
my parents said this is a scam or
nobody's gonna want to buy a 20
bill for 10 bucks like they'll screw it
up right so i became so obsessed with it
and my deep relationship with tony
and the impact he has on people and his
encouragement i'm like
i want to go into the successful i want
to go upstream so my my whole philosophy
was
i can provide you with the way to make
money but if i don't go upstream and
provide you with the right habits
you're going to think i'm a loser and my
doesn't work and i don't like that i
don't want you sitting in starbucks
in five years going i bought that dean
course you can't make money in real
estate it's like no
you can't make money in anything because
you don't have the right habits so i got
obsessed with this
and i started scaling down the real
estate business and going into the
success space wrote millionaire success
habits
and just got obsessed on it and i have
to tell you from going with a
in 2013 my brands and my company we did
over 200 million dollars in sales
to kind of wind that down and start
fresh
i wanted to leapfrog doing 200 million a
year in
in success habits and we took a dip and
of course
fortunately i do well so i didn't let
anybody go and i told the whole team
we're gonna ride i've been here i'm
purposely writing this down so we can
come back out
but i have to tell you i was about a
year in i wrote the book we first
launched it a lot of people are confused
like
you're the real estate guy or the
success guy it's like no you have to be
the success guy to be that big in real
estate right
you know this and i have to tell you
about it a year and a half
in i wasn't getting the momentum i
thought i should and i started
i was losing my confidence like wow
maybe maybe because i'm older maybe
because i i ignored social media i did
because we were the number one
uh show infomercial-wise that was so big
i ignored social media and i see all
these people with a million followers
i didn't barely start an account yet
yeah right and all of a sudden i start
and i got 10
000 followers i'm like wow does
everybody know that look at the impact i
made now i'm like the little guy in town
yeah and
honestly it dinged my confidence i share
that and and i started feeling
a little insecure what did you do about
it um
i started getting my freaking story
straight the same thing let's get my
priorities straight i said listen if i
wanted to stay as the number one real
estate guy is
is it is it my significance you know
what it was it was my significance
my show ran so much no matter where i
went like dean dean dude come in here
sit in the front go to the front row
have this let me buy you dinner all of a
sudden my show was off the air for two
years
and i'm not getting the the love and i'm
like wow
and you know it did it made me a better
man though yeah cause i realized what
the hell am i doing it for i'm doing it
because i want to make an in
at this phase of my life i want to make
an impact on the world i want to be a
badass dad and i want to be a good man
and a good relationship like
that's what makes me successful now like
it's not the money it's not the
significance and when i
decided i didn't care anymore yeah oh my
god like millionaire success habits it
was like it was like a key turn
so it comes in negotiating a lot of
people ask me that dean
you negotiate so well or if i close a
deal someone say
you did all that and there was no
yelling there was no one upset everybody
left the table
feeling happy and that's that's a great
byproduct to let
everybody leave a negotiating table
feeling like they won
that's a major win but negotiating is
everywhere you're negotiating
literally every day if you have children
you're negotiating with them
all the time believe me i know if you're
if you still live with your parents
you're negotiating with them if you have
a husband a wife friends people at work
your boss
the people that work for you negotiating
is something
that we do on a regular basis whether we
realize it or not
so why not get good at it and here's the
thing there's a lot of
persuasive techniques and and strategies
to negotiate to win
but i'm gonna tell you i never knew any
of those and
i would bet to say i'm one of the best
negotiators i know now
i'm not saying that to pat myself on the
back believe me i know there's a million
areas of life that i
suck at that's just absolutely true we
all gotta realize we all are gonna suck
at a lot of things
you only need to be good at one or two
to transform your entire life and that's
that's a true story i know that from
experience but let's get back to
negotiating you see
what most people do and maybe you do and
maybe i i know i've done it
in the past when we're getting ready to
walk into the board room that's an
extreme right walk into the board room
to negotiate
become a part becoming a partner or the
raise or going to the next level or
evolving or
or you're walking in to form a
partnership or you're negotiating a deal
on a house whether you're buying it or
selling it or negotiating a car and you
go
anything what we do is
we rehearse in our mind what we want to
say you see
we want the person on the other side of
the negotiation
to understand us right we want them to
know that man this is why we should be
partners this is why you should lend me
the money this is why
you should um sell me the house at this
price this is why you should buy this
from me this
w we rehearse in our head but i think
our rehearsing is flawed
and let me tell you why it's flawed
because
we are trying to figure out the best way
to describe and to translate into them
why they should do business with us why
we are the right person
why they should sell us the the house or
start the deal or whatever the
negotiating is right or
your spouse your husband your wife your
kids should listen to you we're
rehearsing how many times have you
stayed up late at night
thinking and looping in your head what
you're gonna say
how you're gonna do it what benefits you
have all that and
that's great but it's a flawed way of
thinking and here's what i tell you
through experience
the greatest tool we have to negotiating
are our ears that's right it's our ears
because if you listen i'm going to give
you an example
when i was oh maybe 20 years old
i want to buy a piece of property uh
in in new york right right where i lived
in a little hometown this is one of the
many pieces of property i bought through
solid negotiating um so
this property was for sale for a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars
and uh mrs mary lepreste owned it and a
lot of people had wanted this property
but it wasn't really worth 180
000. it's worth more like 160.
um it was a three unit house she lived
in a basement or first floor and
two people above and everybody has been
trying to buy this house and everybody
was
offering her 165 167 and everybody's
saying
uh mrs lapresti she's a mean old lady
she won't take nothing she's never going
to sell that house
and i sit and i thought to myself now
this is before
you know now that i'm a teacher i want
to look back and see why do i win why
did i win certain areas right
i'm desect dissecting unique processes
in my life what i realized and whether i
was born with or not it's teachable
and and everybody i teach who uses this
their life changes so if you're here
at the podcast you want this tool is i
went and saw mary lou
mrs lapresti and i shut my mouth
and i opened my ears and this may be one
of the first times i realized the power
of listening
because if you ask a few strategic
questions
and shut your mouth then the person on
the other side
will tell you everything you need to
know to close that deal
mary lopresti what i found by just
listening with a few questions
i realized that and i knew but her
husband had died the year prior
and he said when you sell this house you
have to get 180
000 for it and that's it don't take a
dime less
so that was anchored in her head she
wasn't a mean old lady she was listening
to her husband who had passed away
but i also listened and heard her say
that she wanted to sell it
and her whole reason for selling is she
wanted to move to florida
and she wanted to buy a little condo
with no worries
and that's what her dream and her goal
would be
it was listening so what i do is i i i
found her fears i found her desires and
i found her goals
all through what through listening
[Music]
when she got all done i said i knew for
a fact that she had to get 180 000
for that piece of property so i said
mary i'd love
to give you a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars and she lit up
i mean she was glowing this i remember
to this day what a sweet lady
she was glowing she said you would i
said yes that's what your husband wanted
i want to give it to you but
if i'll do that for you you do something
for me i said
you want to go to florida and live with
no worries how much a month do you need
to do that she said two thousand dollars
i said okay i'll give you the 180.
but i'd like to get with no money down
i'd like to give you
thousand dollars a month for two years
uh i'll buy it on contract do a lease
option
or you can hold the paper on it but i'll
give you two thousand dollars a month
for two years
and at the end of that i'll pay you the
balloon
balance of what's left but no down
payment
you pay the insurance on the house yeah
we were leaving house you paid insurance
on it
and zero interest now if you know what
it's like to go into a house with no
money down
no interest someone else paying that
that insurance and i think maybe
in the taxes i went in she was ecstatic
she went down the floor i sent her a
check every month about a year and a
half in i cashed out with the bank and i
got the deal how did i negotiate was i a
hardcore negotiator
did i make her take my money no she used
to make me pasta dinner on sundays until
she left
we became great friends but i look back
at every negotiation that i've won
in my life it wasn't through brute force
it wasn't through power
it wasn't through over explaining myself
myself what it was is me
listening to what people want listening
to their fears listening to their
desires
listening to their goals and then
compute it and translate it in your head
and see if you can make that a win for
everybody i give you a million dollar
racehorse and it's this is the horse
that's going to run
and win the kentucky derby and win the
preakness or whatever
race it would be to make a lot of money
and you had a stable and you had this
horse how would you treat it
would you would you encourage the horse
would you pet it in a really nice way or
would you smack it
right would you be rude to it would you
give it love
would you how how would you feed a
million dollar racehorse
um would you give it junk food would you
give it fritos and
soda and feed it lots of beer and
alcohol or do you think you'd feed it
like whole grains if that's what a horse
eats i'm not great with horses but if
whatever horses would you find organic
grapefruit there's a million dollar
racehorse now
right this isn't just some horse this is
a million dollar resource so would you
feed it the best greens organic take
care of it
here's another thing would you um would
you help it get good sleep or would you
wake it up or
and and not have it sleep good and make
it uncomfortable would you
would you want it to get its rest so it
could heal
would you um would you let it just sit
in the barn
or would you take it out and exercise
and keep it healthy now you don't have
to know anything about horses i'm just
saying
i gave you a million dollar race horse
how would you treat it
now i asked that question because that's
a horse and it's hypothetical and you're
probably like what the heck are you
talking about horses dean
i thought this was the millionaire
success habits podcast and
millionaire's success habits training
what are you talking about a horse for
because we would i believe
we in so many cases would treat
a million dollar racehorse better than
we treat ourselves
you are your million dollar racehorse
you are the only one that can take you
across the finish line you are the only
one
that wins the race we aren't going to be
left
money by an uncle or the government's
gonna just hand out tens of millions of
dollars to us for doing nothing
we're not going to stumble upon an
invention by accident and become rich
overnight
in most cases maybe you hit the lotto
maybe have an uncle
maybe a stumble on an invention but in
most cases we got to find the grit
we got to find the determination we got
to find the passion we have to find the
desire
to get out there and make it happen true
or false
i mean seriously true or false
so if you would treat a million-dollar
racehorse that way then why
don't you treat yourself that way i know
i've gone on stage in front of 10
000 people and i thought i should have
more powerpoint i should have more
reminders and i just remember
walking out and saying i'm here to help
rise these people up to give them
capabilities to change their life it's
my
vision it's my goal it's my obligation
to use my unique ability
to just help these people and live from
my heart and all i could think about is
changing these people's lives
and when i got out there i wasn't
perfect on stage i wasn't robotic and
say the right things and i didn't have
the crisp clear powerpoint but when i
spoke from the heart it overcame all of
that and i get to be one of the best
presenters wherever i go because
i speak from the heart now you might be
saying dean that's your unique ability
and maybe that is
but i know for you in life there are
circumstances where you have to prepare
you have to do a powerpoint you have to
do a presentation and i want to tell you
passion and from the heart always
always wins over over prepared and
thinking from the head
let me just ask you something right now
in the in the crazy presidential race
the gop race you know ben
carson is probably the smartest guy when
it comes to book smart
out of the whole group and i don't watch
the news a lot but i just read a lot and
somebody said this the other day and it
just
it just hit me someone said man ben
carson is probably the smartest guy
in that gop race that's going on
whatever you think of it and i'm not
going to share my opinion
but you know what the guy said when he
was done he's like but we all know the
smartest guy never wins
and i was like wow we all know
that the smartest guy never wins and
what does that mean and it's kind of
what i'm sharing
today i'm not saying you shouldn't be
smart i'm sure and so many of you are
probably
way smarter than i am but what i want to
tell you is enthusiasm and passion and
living from
your heart to me a hundred percent of
the time
outweighs being over prepared and
robotic
and trying to think what to say i hope
i'm getting the right message across
today i
i've had this question from so many
people how are you so easy to talk on
camera on stage
and i never have a good answer and i
really thought through it and that's the
answer
i am here right now doing this video for
you because each week
i want to deliver you a nugget that you
could just place into your life and make
a tiny shift towards a better life
so i don't need a teleprompter i don't
need a script i didn't i i come here and
just want to deliver and it's coming
from my heart now i have practice i've
been on video for
15 years i've been doing these for seven
eight years
and maybe that's not what you do but
you're still
going to have these circumstances where
you have to talk to your children talk
to your co-workers talk to your
employees
and talk to your employer and if you get
stuck in your head that's when you get
stressed that's when you get worried
that's when you try to remember what to
say and you leave and go ah why did i
say that or why didn't i say more
what if you can go in and say why am i
going in and
live with passion and have it come from
your heart then that's truly you and
you're giving the answers you're
supposed to from the real you
not the facade that sometimes life makes
us wear so we have this ideal this image
that everything has to be great that we
don't want any problems because we're
supposed to be happy all the time we're
supposed to be fulfilled they're
supposed to be full of joy and
nothing's supposed to go wrong but the
problems are what make us have the other
side of happiness
the harder our problems and the the way
we find
solutions the way we overcome those
problems the way we process them be sad
be hurt be annoyed
and push it out learn from and move on
the level of our problems is the level
of our success
you know you might want to be in a rock
band and you want to know the feel of
being up on stage
and having all these people loving you
and cheering but if you don't want to go
through the
the practices and the rehearsals and
carrying your stuff in and out of
out of you know dumpy little bars and
stuff like that all those years
then you don't want to take on that
problem of learning in order to have the
reward
for being on stage and being a musician
right if you want to start your own
company and you just want to make the
money and drive the fancy cars like so
many of these
websites you see the billion dollar
website and a bunch of people flashing
money
you know it makes you think oh i want
all that happiness but i don't want the
problems to get there
listen that old saying the the smoothest
rock
is in the roughest part of the stream if
you've had
problems if you are having a problem in
your life
how you overcome that problem how you
figure out solutions
is the level of life that you get to
live well
somebody told me once the level of
complexity you can handle is them
just correlates in so many ways the
amount of money and the happiness you
can achieve
and again i share this with my kids all
the time you don't know tall until you
know short
you don't know happy unless you know sad
you don't know
cloudy days unless you know sunny days
and vice versa so
what i'm sharing with you is your
problems are here to sharpen us
your problems are here to make us
stronger your problems are here
to get the find the solutions and the
more problems you can take on
the more problems you can get through
and come out strong on the other side
the faster your life will go to the next
level i hit it big in real estate by the
time i was 26
27 years old just by taking action
knocking on a million doors and finally
got someone to do a no money down deal
with me when i was 20 and
then another one and i rolled that to
the next deal the next deal and
consistent action
consistent action and and consistent you
know failing and getting back up right
the space between failures is really a
huge determining factor of your success
right it's like
if you can fail fast you can win quicker
right no matter what you're doing
even if you hate it realize it's
temporary and be amazing at it
i i sat down with um john paul digiorio
who started tequila patron and uh
sassoon
and he said he hated come to me a couple
times this week yeah he said he hated
uh he hated when he had a janitorial job
when he was a kid
but he said man it was my job i cleaned
every i used to
the boss came to and said man i lifted
up the desk you cleaned under the desk
he's like the guy thought i loved the
job i hated i just did it the best and i
realized
one of my biggest my first big real my
first real estate deal did over a
million
bucks true story i was fixing a guy's
car
and i'm in the collision shop i'm gonna
be completely transparent i
hated the collision shop i ended up
being the only painter because i got
good at it so every night when everybody
left
i paint for three hours the ventilation
wasn't good i'd have headaches
i hated every inch of it but you'd never
know if you came in you'd be like that
guy
loves being in the collision shop i knew
it was temporary
because don't think i'm just gonna
schlub through this job and then my
my magic will come you'll be screwed
you'll stay there because how you do one
thing
is how you do everything so i so i'm
literally in the collision shop i have
this guy he comes down he's like my god
my car looks great thank you so much we
get talking
come kind of fringe really quick and he
says what are you up to i'm like well
i'm doing this but i'm working on my day
job
my night job is real estate i'm going to
be i'm going to take real estate a whole
nother level he's like what do you got
going on
at that time i was working on a deal for
180
000 to buy an old vineyard and i didn't
have the money
i scraped up every credit card i had i
came up with like 45 grand
the seller agreed to sell it to me for
half down and half in two years
i needed 45 grand i tell this guy the
store i said but i'm going to get it
because
yeah you're going to get it because i'm
going home to get it for you oh my gosh
now what if i was like i hate closure
yeah here's your keys yeah
i made a million dollars on that deal
the first one ever documented i i sold
that property
i killed it on that property killed it
all the neighbors all the neighbors
didn't want me to build on the property
and i was fighting them and then i
realized wow what if i
sell it to them so i sold them all a
piece around and i crushed it
so that's the first thing so no matter
what you're doing find a way to be
enthusiastic knowing that maybe the
universe god whatever you believe is
putting you through your trial
run to deserve that out of all my years
of doing this and and being lucky to
sell i i wasn't a scientist of selling
i was just an innate i had an innate
ability to sell
through that passion and then you get
your ten thousand hours in and all of a
sudden it becomes good right so
on the job training of course right when
i look back
um and if i if i go off in an area that
you want to reel me back and build back
in but
people buy from you will love you will
learn from you will give you a promotion
when they feel understood not when they
understand you
and that was one of the biggest lessons
ever when you watch someone who is so
full of knowledge so full of wisdom and
wants to sell their product sell
themselves
get the raise close the deal at the
board room they're always want to
just exude who they are their
credentials what they have and how they
can solve the problem
and that will get you so far like being
great at sharing who you are will get
you out of egypt
understand how people feel and let them
feel understood it'll get you to the
promised land
right so when you go to an audience or
you're talking to to close a deal
most people want to share most of time
you just need to be quiet and and find
what's going on in that person's life be
be an expert at the temporary state of
mind
like understand what they're going
through at that minute and let them feel
understood when you let people feel
understood when someone's watching you
and you do an amazing job dude i've been
watching you forever and i love what you
do
but when someone watches you and go man
that guy gets me he understands
where i'm going at he understands my
struggles he understands where i want to
go
that's someone i can hitch my cart to
rather than someone who's got great
cadence
credentials and tells uh you can go i
understand that person but i don't think
he understands where i'm at
right right and so the the two things
when it comes to an infomercial comes to
anything with persuasion the two things
i always tell myself is
how do i make sure that person feels
understood and secondly how do i enter a
conversation going on in their mind
not mine you know when you were on your
sister's couch you had different
struggles
right now i come to dohany drive in la
you're in a completely different world a
completely different space flying to the
white house and all the stuff
you got going on the conversations in
your head have changed dramatically
from when you're on your sister's couch
to now yeah so what happens and i've
watched this with marketers and people
in business
as they evolve they hit a certain you
remember that pain that passion
the desire for more i mean you could
probably close your eyes right now and
remember that desire and thing can
am i ever going to make it and and even
a little bit of envy for maybe some of
your buddies who made it
or a little jealousy doesn't mean you
wished ill thoughts on them but it's
like damn it they made it
i don't have it what if i never get it
when if you remember that
pain if you remember that process you
remember that thoughts you will always
serve anybody watching who needs that
but what happens to some people is
as they evolve and you're going to join
the country club maybe you're going to
get married you're gonna move to the
suburbs now you've got an accountant and
you've got
two assistants and now should i hire a
salesperson you've got a private jet and
then
is the pilot gonna be late and then and
then you know and then you're like i got
a facebook team should i outsource the
facebook marketing
and all of a sudden your conversations
change
you get to do an interview or you pitch
on camera or you do an infomercial
and all of a sudden you're having
conversations in your head and your
audience feels disconnected yeah and you
don't even know why
like what did i miss because now you're
asking questions
of a completely different group because
you've evolved so
the two things again i always go back to
even before i turn a camera on before i
go on stage before i do an infomercial i
said
people buy from you love you adore you
will learn from me if they feel
understood and i want to enter
conversations going on
in their heads not mine here's the deal
if it's
july i want to know how are you doing
with your new year's resolutions how are
you doing
with your goals for this year now i
don't care when it is you're listening
to this if you end up listening in
january
july november december it doesn't matter
but it's time for a checkup
because if it's the middle of the year
you can do this at any time of year
it's time to decide what goals are you
lagging on what goals
are you not fulfilling at the
the pace of in which you wanted to
achieve
what goals have you given up on what
goals have you allowed the slip and you
fall back into
old routines if you want to make this
year better than last year and
and incremental growth is amazing even
if it's a tiny if it's a millimeter
it's growth then it's time to do a few
things it's time to revisit your goals
you should be revisiting your goals on a
weekly basis no matter what in fact when
you really want to change your life you
revisit your goals on a daily
basis that's right write your goals look
at them every single day if you don't
look at them they're just something
that you want to achieve they become a
new year's resolution that are gone by
february
if you want to achieve goals you got to
write them you got to immerse yourself
in them you got to stare at them you got
to
feel them you got to manifest them you
got to visualize they already happened
goals just don't happen you have to work
on it but this is a great time of year
again no matter when you listen to us
but if you listen to it fresh and it's
july for you
you're more than halfway through the
year and sometimes
sometimes we write down too many goals
in the beginning of the year so now
we're at a point where you got four or
five goals and none of them
are getting the momentum that you hope
maybe it's your weight maybe it's your
income maybe it's starting the new
business
so here's my advice right now today
decide which goals you should just shut
off you know sometimes to have a
breakthrough we have to break something
sometimes in order to achieve we have to
quit
something we have to throw it away so i
would say
if there's a few goals on your list and
some of them you're just not going to
hit and it's
causing all of them to be delayed then i
would literally
park two or three of your goals and say
i'm going to start those in the
beginning of next year but the ones that
are left
you're going to achieve if you're
listening to me you're somebody who
wants to work
on your own evolution you want to work
on your own growth you want to be a
better version of you more money more
happiness more true i get that we just
talked about that right
but man doesn't somebody else live
inside of us like the past version of us
the version that school may have created
or parents may have created
or an ex-spouse may have created or your
surroundings or the news or society
or where you grow up it's like we're
running away from the evil bastard
that's what i'm calling them right now
living inside as well simultaneously
simultaneously we're being a better
version of us
and all i'm going to share with you
today is acknowledge it look out for
that person
look out for the person talking that
really isn't the person that you want to
be maybe it's the person you used to be
maybe it's the person other people think
you are but it's not the person you want
to be
and all i can say is be on the lookout i
want to tell you this story this morning
i just got back from as i'm talking to
you uh last week
i jumped on a plane and flew to marco
island and spoke at tony robbins wealth
mastery
amazing that the wealth mastery students
all tony robinson so
you guys are all the same on fire
motivation
inspired ready to learn ready to gain
the wisdom
so rock that stage was amazing uh i
drive across the pa
the the the uh that's where the
okeechobee
lake is across the pa in florida i drove
across the swamp
god there's a better i can't think but
the everglades there it is oh my god i'm
not that dumb i promise
so i drive across the everglades i go
over to miami dad some business there
the next day i did a podcast
with grant cardone that was great but it
it took like five days and my kids
went out of town two days before with
their mom to
uh uh indiana to see her my
to see their family right so i didn't
see my kids for like
six days so no big deal doesn't seem
like a big deal it's a big deal to me
success in my life right now is is
keeping my business growing learning
growing becoming a better version of me
and being a badass dad and i miss my
kids i never go any place where i'm not
going to see more than three days
i just don't but i didn't see him for
almost six days so i get home
last night and it was a little late
didn't get much time with him so this
morning
this morning i really wanted to see my
kids so i got up super early i went to
the gym at five so i wouldn't miss them
i get back on time
and this all makes sense to you so we'll
get to the learning part of this in a
moment
i get back and i i shower quick and i
make them an amazing breakfast i cut up
all kinds of fresh veggies
i sauteed garlic olive oil onions
peppers uh no peppers didn't like
peppers
um asparagus and zucchini
and fresh tomatoes out of the garden i
make that up i mix it with eggs a couple
bagels
cut up fruit i lay out the whole table
for them i get up and i miss my kids i
hadn't seen them and i want them to
run to me and be happy and joyful and so
excited to see me and they were kind of
like
hey what's up dad i was like all right
got a little butt hurt but you know
that's kids
um and then we ate breakfast and my
daughter had
forgot something um that was her
responsibility to forget
and i'm telling this again stick with me
here my daughter forgets something and
she wants us to go get it
love and logic parenting parenting that
helps kids be more responsive i was like
oh brian i'm so sorry you forgot that
but you were reminded twice and you
forgot it so the consequence is you're
not gonna have it today
and she got really mad at me and it's
hard because i miss them i just want to
be the dad that
loves them that just says okay i'll do
whatever you want bree just
her name is brianna to do it but so i
did that part
so right taught her a lesson she'll
never forget it again even if she's a
little upset with me
parenting is like credit card either pay
now or you pay later you're paying
eventually
so i'm deciding to pay it now so i have
such great kids
but then she got mad at me and she was
rude to me
and and my daughter never is and then
she went to walk by me and i went to
give her a hug and she kind of pushed me
away
and you know what i did i snapped that
ugly bastard living inside of me took
over and i said to my daughter i dropped
the f-bomb i'm so embarrassed
yes i swear a little bit but never in
front of my kids i was like don't
f don't treat me that way bri i don't
deserve it and i was rude to her and she
started to cry
it's a terrible parenting moment
terrible but that was the little bastard
that lived inside of me that's who
that's how i was raised that's how my
dad talked to me that's how my dad
treated me dad's a great guy that's how
all he learned he would lose he
he'd knock stuff off the table he'd flip
out yell break
punch the window break the windshield
while we're driving
i didn't even know he lived inside of me
still there after all these years that's
what i do for a living
it's my own daughter i love her more
than any other human being on this earth
besides my son
and i did it and as soon as it popped
out of my mouth
i could have leaned into it and go no
that's who i am as soon as it popped out
i stopped
i was like oh my god that's not me
that's not the man i want to be that's
not the example i want to be that's not
who i am
i composed myself and i went and sat
with my daughter and apologized and told
her dad made a monster mistake he said
yes i missed you
yes you should have not forgot your
thing when you were reminded three times
no you shouldn't be rude to your dad but
none of that gives an excuse
for me to act the way i just acted to
you brianna that that was really a bad
parenting moment and i said i'm sorry
and i'm still
a little shaken by she accepted as i
accept your apology dad and amongst her
tears
she gave me a hug i even called her on
her way to school onto summer camp
and i apologize again but i'm upset with
me but i'm gonna
feel that pain today because that ugly
little bastard living inside of that
rude bastard living inside me i want him
dead and gone forever so my point to you
is remember that it lives inside of us
remember there's old ways things were
brought up things we were taught
that are here we're working on our
growth you're listening to me because
you want more but that person still
lives there when it comes out
acknowledge it and figure a way to kill
him once and for all
and we can do that by just being aware
of it
we can do that by saying different words
we can do that by taking pauses we can
do that
and look how that makes us feel compared
to doing it the opposite way we can read
more we can learn more we can learn from
those doing at the highest level
possible instead of our own trial and
error
do exactly what you're doing ever since
that journey and starting before that
with more to millions
i realized that people are searching
like
and again i i digress sometimes but
everybody's in a vehicle
like your your wealth creation vehicle
whether that's a job you don't like or a
job you do like or a business you
started or a
it's crushing or business it's not doing
great you have this vehicle
and when this vehicle is not working
we're looking on the road of all the
other shiny cars i was like oh man i
tried
selling stuff on amazon that's not
working i'm going to go in the car
business the real estate business i'm
going to go in the speaking business the
the nutrition business the supplement
and you're looking for another car to
jump in
and i realized people jumped from car to
car to car their whole life looking for
satiation looking for satisfaction
looking to make more money
and i got to see it firsthand tom
because i was in the business of
teaching people how to make money with
real estate
and when they would call into customer
service when they would send in for a
refund or i'd see them
at an event they never said ever i tried
your real estate
stuff it sucks never we used to send
surveys to list and go how come you're
not making money yet is it you know the
time effort energy dean's training sucks
one percent would pick the training
sucks
and what i realized over all these years
is that and the reason i wrote
millionaire success habits is you could
literally give someone a business on how
to sell
20 bills for five bucks and they'd
screwed up
because of their beliefs because of the
fear of rejection because the fear of
selling because of the fear of marketing
because
other people told them they couldn't or
they feel they need certain criteria
they need initials
at the end of their name like they they
need all these things
and at the end of the day what you wrote
uh
your impact theory you call them beliefs
yeah impact theory
beliefs it's kind of the same beliefs
that are in my book but it's also the
same beliefs that are in
three quarters of the books that you
have in your shelf now and the
incredible people you've interviewed
and i just saw that if we can give
people if we can go upstream
if you can stop jumping from vehicle to
vehicle the vehicle you're in
might be the right vehicle but you don't
have the right habits or the right
beliefs or the right rules whatever you
want to call it
my books habits so i call them habits
but it's really the foundation for
success so you can
overcome the obstacles you don't let
negative people in your life
steer you in different directions it
doesn't you know
even people ask me about productivity
people say how do you get so much done
how do you
run a business and still coach little
league and baseball and stuff how do you
do all those things
it's because of just simple success
habits like
i i just wrote something on this
recently i said
you have to treat your decisions for
productivity like binary thinking which
is x's and o's black and
black or white yes or no is this moving
me toward a better version of myself a
wealthier version a happier version
or is it not successful people make this
doesn't serve that better version
i'm not doing it right so there's all
these little rules
and i think i think and i know this
even when i met with branson i think
people meet someone who's successful
people meet you and they're like okay
what is it like like there's this little
like okay nobody's looking
one that lights up and like here it is
right and it's not
the big thing like even when i was
sailing with branson i'm wait like i
wanted to say to him
so what is it you know but it's not when
i get done talking to him for three
hours he's got the same habits that you
have the same
rules that you have written down on that
plaque that's amazing in my opinion it's
never the big things
it's all the little changes you can make
in your life and none of them are
are dramatic at each level it's like
just
following these little principles that
have worked for so many years and you
start put them in your life and all of a
sudden decisions start going easier
the money starts to change the business
starts to do good the thoughts in your
head start to project a bigger future
rather than
than than negativity i i think it's the
i think it's the build up of the habits
or beliefs
so david keckage is a friend a friend of
a friend really but i met him a couple
times
great guy and he was paralyzed from the
neck
down a guy that was into health and
fitness and
taking care of his body and living in a
wheelchair and not be able to do
anything for himself
he's thrived thrived on a whole new
level and does so much
for innovating and helping other people
with the same
circumstances but the reason i'm sharing
this is because he did 30 keckish
credos to live by if you want to live a
joyful life this is somebody in a
wheelchair now remember the obstacles he
has every single day when he wakes up
can barely swallow on his own i mean
think about that right
so one of his credos is if you
live life the hard way it's easy and if
you live life
the easy way it's hard and here's what i
equate that to we have to pick our pain
think about that now let's just use a
silly analogy is working out easy
no it's a pain in the butt going to the
gym it might be hard it's painful right
but not exercising and not working out
will that be painful be painful someday
in your life will it be
that you're out of shape and you get
heart failure we'll be out of shape and
you're overweight and get diabetes
we'll be out of shape that you don't
have muscle tone and you break a hip
someday i mean you might be young not
thinking about that now but
living the easy way of no working out
can that be more painful absolutely what
about eating healthy can it be painful
to
eat the right food and not choose the
greasy fried food and not get up and
have a coffee and a donut and try to
have
green juices and green live green
veggies and eat lean protein and do
those things is that a pain
yeah and it's kind of hard it's the hard
way it's the hard way but it gives you
an easy life so you're full of abundance
joy you i mean you feel healthy you want
to thrive you can run if you have kids
you can move or when you have kids
someday
or you can live to see your
great-grandchildren right so
living the hard way meaning do the right
thing eat the right food work out maybe
a little hard
but that's the path to an easy life if
you want to live the easy way now and
not work out and eat terrible food
maybe it's temporarily easy but will
that give you long-term health
and satisfaction and even if you make
the money without your health are you
really wealthy
no right but think about that also with
your success this is the
millionaire success habits podcast but
the foundation for success is if i
if i gave you the tools to make money
but didn't share with you that you
should be fulfilled and satisfied and
healthy
then then i'm just a fraud because it
all ties together if you got money out
of the way today
the next thing you would be worrying
about or thinking about is how do you
live the best version of you how do you
be the best mom
dad son brother cousin you know a
spouse right so i want you to think
about it when it comes to your
next level of income next level of
long-term wealth or starting a side
business
the easy way is hard in the long run the
easy way is to settle
for the job that you're in that that's
killing you the easy way
is to look for a magic money machine
online and not spend time with your
habits
the easy way is hope that someone does
it for you the easy way is the hope
the government changes the rules and
more money comes you that's all the easy
way what do you do
you sit around and hope for years and
years and years and then you look back
at the end of your life
and time is gone you look back at the
end of your life and you go you i wish
i would have gone after it harder in the
beginning
so the hard way may be listening to
podcasts like this
reading books like millionaire success
habits and and all the other books that
come from people that are actually doing
it or get enrolled in courses or get
involved in a mastermind or dig deep
to find the research to know if you're
in the right path if you're in a future
proof
industry or not yeah that might be a
little harder now it might be harder now
to wake up when everybody in your family
tells you you're insane when your
friends and relatives say you should be
happy with the life you have or people
tell you you don't have enough money you
don't have the right education you don't
live in the right area
you're on the right pedigree you didn't
get the right degree you people can all
tell you that
and it's hard to overcome them it's hard
to overcome getting up
and going for it's hard to overcome
procrastination it's hard to overcome
getting sucked into social media
go check your bank account and two hours
go by going down rabbit holes of stupid
things
that's hard it's hard if you're in a
relationship and the other person thinks
that you should be
strict and steady in your job and do the
right thing and and follow the rules
it's hard to step out of the line when
98 of the world listen to somebody else
they live a mediocre life they live an
okay life
do you want to live an okay life or do
you want to live an outstanding life
do you want to live a good life how's
your relationship good
how's your health good how's your income
good how's your job good do you want to
live good
or do you want to live excellence do you
want to live great do you want to live
an outstanding life
if we do then david keckage has it right
the keckish credo that if you want to
live the
the hard way now gives you the easy life
the easy way now gives you the hard life
if you want more success get bigger
problems
as simple as that sounds like oh dean
that was so enlightening no it is
because here's this is simple the lowest
form like
i just started realizing i want bigger
problems because i remember the stress
of my first real estate deal
where i made probably five grand yeah
right worked my ass off was stressing
worried that the town didn't want to
give me a permit then the seller was
falling through and i was running out of
money
it was it was so stressful
and then i remember you know a couple
months ago i signed a 18 million
deal and there was this same exact
amount of stress it doesn't matter and
and again i i i say that i i i said i
judge myself i don't ever want to come
across pretentious or saying i'm looking
at my 18 million deal i don't mean that
i just want you to know
that the stress you feel to pay your
bills or get ahead or it's the same
stress
whether you're making 10 100 10 million
or 100 million a year
it feels the same so if it feels the
same then why not
avoid lower end problems so you could
spend time solving bigger ones
i mean i'm in a phase of my life i'm not
you
if i order medium rare steak at a
restaurant
and they bring me well done chicken i
just eat it so do i who gives you
why i'm the same way it's like somebody
cuts me off in track
traffic and then flips me off i'm like
wow they need bigger problems
traffic is bugging you that much you'll
never be successful so know that
if you're annoyed because a friend
doesn't ask you to go to the mall or
someone cut you off in traffic or you
think a friend
offended you or you think a co-worker is
being a little rude then you're screwed
because you're worrying about the wrong
things
spend that energy on solving big
problems and you accomplish big things
there's a part actually that i wanted to
go over in your book called the seven
levels deep
it is yeah and this is an exercise that
you do right and what is this exercise
for okay and how does it go okay so
seven levels deep was probably the
biggest
impact uh the biggest thing in the
impact of my life
ever really yeah one one day so i hired
a guy named joe stump do you know joe
stump no
great guy uh he's in the marketing world
but i hired him because i want more
engagement with my students so it's
it's all about if you can get somebody
to digest some of your book if somebody
will read 30 pages of your book they'll
read the whole book but how do you get
them to the first 30 pages so i'm always
obsessing and
trying to create ethical bribes whatever
to get you to take action right
um we know books work it's the books and
the actions so i was
so anyway so joe comes in and he's i
said i want to do whatever i can
and he said have you ever done the seven
levels deep
i don't know where he got it from this
is probably about eight years ago she
was
two so about eight years ago um and i
said
if it's good just give it to me right
right i'll take it and he's like i want
to go through it with you i'm like
listen and i paid joe 10 grand for a
half a day of consulting at the time and
he's like i said i want to go through i
just want it
because i won't give it to you unless
you do it so we sit there and what the
seven levels deep is is finding
everybody wants to know your purpose
and what's what's this meaning of life
and what's my why and all that i get
and it's kind of played out but i don't
know if anything really gets
to the heart of the of it as simple as
this so what it basically was he's like
why would you give me 10 grand for a
half a day
and i said because i want to create a
company that stands out from everybody
else i want to
engage more students change more lives
and he basically said to me that's a
really great answer so i asked you why
i'm here
and you said you want to engage more
students and and get more people change
your life so why is it important for you
to engage more students and change
people's lives and i remember saying you
know there's a lot of people in this
industry that shouldn't be here and
there's some great people i want to help
rise all boats of the good and push the
rest
out i want to leave a legacy for my kids
so he said okay i asked you why you paid
me 10 grand
i'm not gonna go through this whole
thing and he's like you did this you
know you said you wanted to stand out
and you want to leave a legacy so why is
it important to leave a legacy
and the whole point is asking the
previous question seven times
i took that that day by the time i got
to the third question
what happens is the third when there was
three questions left i should say he
asked me four times
it switched from my head to my heart and
i felt
my physiology change i felt my emotions
change i felt like tears welling up and
when he asked me i don't even remember
what the fourth thing i said
but the third thing i said was i never
want to go backwards
and it got me thinking about things i
haven't thought about in years i didn't
like being the kid with hand-me-downs
and i'd make my parents drop me off down
the street with their junky car and
i'd go to lunch and this is not a poor
me i my life was designed to be exactly
the way it was i wouldn't be the man or
the father i am today but
there was days i'd go to school without
lunch money and i just tell my buddies
i'm not hungry
because we didn't have a buck right so i
never want to go back there and i
felt that emotion and it it it hit me
so hard i'm like that's what it is and
he's like well there's two more left so
he said dean why is it important that
you never go backwards
and i'm like i i don't know and it hit
me and i thought my kids
i i i just want to give them options i
don't want to raise entitled kids or
brats but i want to give them options
that i didn't have and i'm like that's
it
so he's like well that's not really it's
seven it's not nine it's not five it's
seven levels deep
and by now i'm crying cause i'm thinking
about my kids literally and i got half
my staff there and i'm like
just weeping and it came to me he said
why is that important and it just hit me
and i never knew
why i worked so hard since i was cutting
firewood in high school and did all the
stuff i said
i need to be in control of my life and
these emotions flooded in my
everybody's got their thing right but
for me and i'm saying this because i
want you at home
to be or when you're watching this
listen this i realized that my parents
were married nine times when i was a kid
so i moved 20 times by the time i was
19. different step brothers steps both
parents were married
five for my dad five for my mom four my
oh my gosh yeah
it's crazy always moving like military
kids
know what that feels like right so i'd
be in a cul-de-sac with a new step-dad
step brother step-sisters have the bike
come home one day and my mom's like
we're moving again and then i'm moving
my dad moving to my grandma so i had
this crazy hopscotch my whole
certainty there was no certainty so what
i realized at that moment lily i'm
bawling loose i mean like literally
crying it's like i don't want anybody to
ever tell me when to move how to dress
how to live
how to work how i'm going to raise my
kids it's definitely not going to kiss
somebody's ass for
money right and i realized at that
moment my why was i
i don't want to be a control freak i
just want to be in control when i was 27
i retired both my parents
i stopped worrying about them i took
care of my grandmother i take care of
some like
so i got those problems out of the way
and when i anchored that in
and you watching at home it's like if
you think you're
watching this because you want to be an
entrepreneur you want or you already are
if you're watching this you've already
had great success in your life you want
that next level or maybe it's income
or or better health or better diet or
better physiology whatever it is you
want
so many times we think it's because i
want to get out of that job
i want this freedom i just want more
money i want to take the better
vacations
and it's seven times deeper than that
and when you find that
and the reason i know this not only
because it wasn't just transformative to
me
transformational to me is i did live
events in las vegas for six years
straight
every single month there was 400 people
in the room that paid 20 grand to go to
real estate events
real estate so about five and a half
years i did them um
every month in las vegas so once a month
i'd fly in and
that was like the highest level and i'd
every single month i'd raise i'd get
to pick somebody out of the audience and
i'd say come on up let's do this seven
levels deep like i got it man i know
what it is and i'm like okay so
like i'm gonna give you a quick example
i i won't beat this up but this is so
important
because when you feel fatigued when you
want to say no when you don't want to go
to the gym when you don't want to make
that sales call
when you don't want to get your funnel
working when you don't want to start new
when you don't want to say
no to someone you should say no to or
say yes to someone else you should say
yes to
literally for me still i fall back on my
why when i think of my kids and going
backwards
and being in control i could push
through anything nothing will stop me a
bad day
i don't know what it's like to be sick
because my mind i can program my brain
to just
power through because i focus
foundationally on this why
right so i get i remember this guy who's
awesome big dude he had dreadlocks he
was like six foot seven i mean
six foot five he was huge just awesome
dude he comes up he's like man i like
pick me up he gives those big hugs
so i said why are you here he's like i
already know dude you're not gonna get
seven levels on me
you're not gonna i've already done the
exercises i'm here because in my
neighborhood
there's no dads there's not enough dads
in my neighborhood i grew up without a
dad
these kids need dads so i'm making money
in real estate and i'm starting this
youth group i already had that we get
dads together and we go spend these days
he has
he had this amazing story and i mean i
melted on the first one
i said why is that important he goes
dude what do you mean why is that
important
of course it's important and he's
laughing he's joking he gives me another
reason
i want more money because i want to
build a building for it but i could tell
he's still in his head
he gets the number two or one and his
everything changed on him he gets small
and he starts crying i mean like
uncontrollable crying
and he gets to his number one he's like
my mom raised a good boy but when she
died nine years ago i was a drug addict
and she never saw the man she created
and she said i'm showing her in heaven
what a man she i'm saying right now
wow physical good he said that and i
said he said
i'll never stop now i'll never stop and
again we all have our own reasons for
doing stuff but when you get to the
heart of why
you're watching why you do what you do
it's so much deeper than what you think
and i forget sometimes i i hope i don't
sit here and feel like seem like i got
my life all figured out i've been
blessed to have
more i've had more blessings in my life
than i ever could imagine if somebody
would have told me at 25 this is where
i'd be i'd say
impossible so i appreciate my blessings
but i'm not
i'm not perfect at all this stuff but
when i practice these habits when i
think through this when i
recognize my why the days that i'm off
track the days i think i
bit off more than i can chew with the
days where i feel like i plateaued when
i go back to that y it's like
game over and you're not getting in my
way nothing is my
stepdad who has been my stepdad since i
was nine years old so i've known him for
41 years
my he was my mom's high school
sweetheart they went to the prom
together
and then he went away the army she
married my dad and then they got back
together
um great guy uh two days ago he had a
stroke in the middle of the night
kind of haven't been haven't slept much
since i had a stroke
and then the next day he had a heart
attack and he's not doing so great i've
been spending a lot of time with him
and i see him sitting
he can't talk because of the stroke and
i see him looking around
and looking at his family and looking at
my mom and his kids
and i just know it's like
like you've heard so many times in the
book seven habits of highly successful
people
you know that covey talks about coming
to the end of your life
and literally being in the hospital and
hearing the buttons and the beeps and
hearing people talk about you
when you look who do you want to see who
do you want to be there
and and what do you want them to be
saying about you think about that i'm
not trying to be morbid i'm just in this
space for me
personally but here's what i know is how
long are you going to put off
what you crave so bad if you're watching
a millionaire success habits or
listening to a millionaire success
habits podcast
you want another level of life but
there's things in your life that right
now
you should be saying no to right now you
should be saying yes to and going after
but we think we have all this time
listen my stepdad he's young he's only
76 years old
i bet to say looking through his eyes
that
he just felt like he'd have forever
listen today i'm just going to be
i'm more personal in the in the podcast
than i am in any other place
today i broke down and cried in a way i
haven't in a really long time
i'm parking so i can talk here i i broke
down today and i cried really hard i
cried down because i
cried because some of it was just
looking through his eyes and i could see
the sadness
of of wow is this it is it over
and i'd love for you to just take a
moment
and think about if this was the end of
your life
what should you be saying no to right
this second what should you be saying
yes to right this second here's what i
know
people who say money can't buy happiness
or doesn't money doesn't make you happy
to me
you haven't made enough and you haven't
given enough away so get rid of that
money is evil thing that's just
foolish i i'm blessed to be able to do
what i want to do when i want to do it
because i got money out of the way
that's great so you might be saying good
for you dean but i'm just saying so
don't
just what i'm saying is if money is
important that next level is important
so you can
pay for speed so you can pay for freedom
so you can pay for control of your life
then
go for it but find the balance find out
why you're doing it right now what does
success mean
to you you know what it means to me in
my life right now is that i get to do
what i want when i want with my kids
they're they're nine and 11. they're
growing so fast i can't slow it down
so i want to coach the league i want to
coach softball i want to go to every
game
but here's what i know i've even slacked
and you know
i love doing this training i love
sharing with you because
if i'm not congruent if i don't share a
message that i actually live that i'm
kind of full
for lack of a better word i'm just
someone babbling you're not here because
you just want to hear someone talk you
want to hear someone who's been through
it who can admit their flaws
i love saying this i love talking about
it because i screw this up sometimes
i want to tell you something this is
really personal today
at four o'clock my daughter she's eleven
she pitches she's a great pitcher she
made the all-star team but
today they're they're going to the local
high school team
that's really good arcadia high school
and i got them tickets i got them all
set up but i had work to do so i was
going to let them go and
haul her friends and screw that because
of what i'm going through with lenny and
seeing that
what am i going to get some more emails
done work on my next million dollars i'm
not saying at the brag i'm just saying
what am i gonna do or am i when i'm on
my death bed am i gonna say i wish i
answered more emails
or i wish i went to that softball game
with my daughter and watched her face
when she saw high school girls play
not even a question then at 6 30 the
game's at four at 6 30.
i missed my son's last two practices
because i was really busy
but the two before that i've been
coaching him since he was four years old
coaching assistant coach glove on out
there getting dirty
but i have to tell you this year this
last year i've kind of let the coaches
coach
and i sat back on the on the you know
the the bench and
answered emails and got work done i
figured it was a great place to get two
hours worth of work done while my son
was out there
and i realized today screw that you see
what's right here in my passenger seat
that's my baseball glove today there's
shorts look i got a pair of shorts
in the back seat i'm going to change it
in the car and today i'm getting dirty
again i'm going back and practicing
with my son again today screw that when
when i'm wearing lenny my stepdad's name
is lenny where i'm on lenny is
i'm not going to be saying
boy thank god all those baseball
practices after the age of nine i got
all those emails done
now screw that i'm gonna say i was on
the field looking at my son
in the eye him watching me be intent be
in the moment
live in the now love what you provide
people so much
that you feel like it's a disservice not
to get them to say yes
did you hear what i said love your
products so much
and make it so perfect that you feel
you're doing people a disservice if they
don't say yes if i don't get you
to buy my book millionaire success
habits i'm doing you a disservice
if i don't get you to listen to my
podcasts on a weekly basis if i don't
get you to watch my weekly wisdoms
i'm doing you a disservice so i will do
everything in my power
to get you to say yes so that's step one
love what you do
once you love what you do and you know
you positively affect people's lives if
you're selling drugs
don't use this this is unfair if you're
selling cigarettes or teaching people
how to get hooked on gambling
then i you have to look in the mirror
and deal with that but if you're
providing a service or you're sliding
real estate
stop whatever it is that you do if
you're doing it you you got to love it
so much that you want to get people in
it no matter what
my first apartment house it was an old
run down massive lesson here everybody
it was it was an old run down apartment
a mansion like i mean beat up old big
house
and i ended up getting the house for no
money down and i converted it into 10
apartments
so what was cool is i i'd fix one up i
was living in it while i fixed it
and then as soon as it was done i'd rent
it and move in one not done but i got
through all 10 of them crazy
so now i have this 10 unit apartment
house it's doing great for me i'm i'm
19 20 years old you know it's bringing
me in five grand a month
net net which was a gazillion dollars
because now i'm not i'm living for free
yeah and this is and plus it's building
value so i got no money down refinanced
it pulled some cash out i was i used
that money to go into the next one long
story short
the had a huge long so every saturday
because my dad was born during the
depression my dad grew up with if you
could do it yourself you don't pay
anybody
right so every saturday i'd spend five
hours i had a massive lawn i'd mow i
have allergies so my eyes are tearing
i'm weed whacking this
[ __ ] hits your legs and it's just and
then one day i realized
wow i'm mowing my lawn a whole day i
hired a kid down the street for 50 bucks
to mow my lawn
and my he's mowing on my dad pulls in
true story no zero exaggeration i tell
to my dad all the time he's like sorry i
was wrong
my dad pulls in he goes and that's how
my dad talks me whether you think a true
night goes mr big shot you
finally went too far you're so big now
that you're going to pay someone to mow
your lawn when you can do it
and he got so mad that he left and he
hit the gas and he
it was gravel driveway and he dented
this out of the side of my car was just
like
i'm like ah and he left and maybe he
gave me the finger when he was leaving
or something like that
that's my dad he's got an italian hot
head right and he left
and it was so profound that i knew at
that moment i was on to something
i really did i i'd love to say it was
this epiphany and the sky opened up but
i was like
wow my dad still struggles and what i
realize and this is what i want to share
with you
is i realized an roi on my time
at that time i had 15 apartments i had
two houses being built i had a collision
shop and a used car
dealership if i went down to the used
car dealership and sold one car i
probably netted about two grand a car
back then i sold lower end cars
so in that day without mowing the lawn
if i sold one car
it cost me 50 to mow the lawn i made two
grand or if i drove around that day and
found my next apartment house
could be tens of thousands of dollars
and it just hit me it was so
profound at that moment that i'm going
to start equating things i do with an
roi
yes it's like if i and and the great
part is if you keep
noodling it it doesn't matter if
something costs you 500
an hour if you're working in your unique
ability you can make 10 grand an hour
still pay someone to do it you know we
get so lost
in being something for someone else
do we really remember who we are answer
that question honestly think about that
i mean
maybe you were somebody for your parents
when you were younger
uh maybe you were someone for your
teachers maybe you were someone for
your first girlfriend your first
boyfriend maybe you're someone right now
for your husband or your wife or
or your current situation with your
parents or maybe you're someone
for your boss maybe you're a certain
someone at church on sundays
and maybe you're another certain someone
when the door is closed and no one's
watching
so who the hell are you i mean what what
version of you is really you
and i wanna i wanna that's a thought
provoking question
on purpose because life is going by
so fast it's unbelievable and i mean at
least for me i don't know about you but
the last five years oh my god it's on
hyper speed i i would slow it down my my
kids right now or
as i'm sharing this are nine and 11 like
five
minutes ago there were babies and that
means in five minutes from now they'll
be graduating high school and
five minutes after that they'll be you
know getting married having their own
kids
so let me ask you are you wasting any
time
being someone that's not really you you
see
we are these and we all do it don't
think as i say that
i'm perfect and i'm just this oneness
and per no
i'm not but i'm acknowledging it and i'm
aware of it and i work on it because
here's what i think
i think the ideal happiness like we're
all looking for happiness we're all
looking for
more yay and less ah right in our lives
i think we can all agree that's true but
when you're being someone else
for everybody else are you really being
true to
the best version of you see we're
someone in front of all these other
people
and we're someone if we're a boss or for
employee or any of that stuff right
but then who's the person late at night
when no one's around uh who's the person
when you're thinking and your mind's
just going
when when the ego's not there when the
outside influences aren't there when
maybe you're a little bit more
vulnerable who is that person you see
here's what i know here's what i believe
the definition of success
is first it's knowing what success means
to you i know i'm being successful when
i know i'm being successful when i'm
spending time my family i know i'm being
successful when
i have complete control of my life i
know i'm being successful when i have
freedom to make the choices i want
i first off is knowing what success
means to you
and but i think there's another layer
like there's another level and another
the next level is i know i'm being
successful
when i know who i am and i'm just being
that
imagine being congruent in all areas of
your life
everything like your phone you could
leave it unlocked and open no matter
where you go
if your boss was listening in or your
employees were listening in or your
business partner was listing in on
every conversation of your life you
wouldn't care if your spouse your
boyfriend your girlfriend
your parents were hearing what you said
when no one was around if you're friends
then when you're with one group of set
or one set of friends and you go with
another group
if they could hear everything you'd say
it wouldn't matter imagine
how successful when i talk success yes i
mean money but i mean all the other
pieces too
imagine how successful we would be if we
were just
one version there wasn't any hidden
compartments do we all have secrets of
course
i don't care who you are unless maybe
mother teresa we all have secrets we all
have things that maybe we don't want
everyone to know about but if what if we
could work
what if we could work overtime
to become so congruent that there's only
one version of you
i'd love people to to really think about
is their thoughts
you have you ever read the untethered
soul no it's a you got to put it on your
list
how about eckhart totally the power now
sure yeah i read that
yes okay so an untethered soul is for me
it's it's that
and and so much more it's a it's a great
book um so
i don't know if you had another question
so i think so i'll reframe that it's
that one
but if there's one specific question i'd
love for people to say
how do you be the observer of your
thoughts
and that's something do you yeah and
that's something i would
i would i the only reason i see this is
because i've been obsessed with it for
the last
three years because i want to be the
observer of thoughts
immediately and i'm not there yet i want
it to trigger because when you're having
a bad day
an angst day a stressful day you feel
off
or overwhelmed most of the time it's
just the thoughts we're having in that
particular day
and when you can look back and view
those thoughts
you can make a decision to throw them
out or not let that spin you up or
feel it for 10 minutes and then throw it
out but when you leave them there
they just linger and the more i've
become
aware of my thoughts the more i've
evolved as a person so
again i'm sitting here because my
daughter you're probably bored to death
on love you
uh she's doing great over there i'm
gonna tell a story about her
i am trying to observe my thoughts as
they happen so i don't know if
she'll remember this but we were we were
and i'm sharing this is my story but i
want you to put yourself in these shoes
this could be your husband your wife
your kids your co-worker your partner
people you do business with employer
employees but we're at breakfast and
breakfast is really important to our
family we have breakfast
every single day and and i cook for them
most of the time
and so we sit at breakfast and try to
have conversations about gratitude and
all this kind of stuff and
my son brody was obsessed with these
crayons
and they were like these crazy colors
they weren't red they were like aqua
blue marine
something so i'm sitting there using
them and
and i pull it out oh god this is a cool
color and he names it i'm telling for a
reason so i pull out another he names
all i was at 25 or 50 in that pack
so he names all of them these big long
names i'm like
dude what an incredible gift i couldn't
memorize these if i spent a month trying
that's not
how my brain thinks but that's him he's
this structured organized kid
so brie uh she says to me i can do that
so i don't know if you remember this one
but she studied it
and like five minutes later on the
second one she didn't remember i'm like
we're all blessed with different gifts i
couldn't remember he does that but
my daughter is the inventor she comes up
with ideas that are real not
not kid invention she's going to be
amazed she's going to be the visionary
my son's going to be the implementer if
you ever read rocket fuel that's the two
kids i have
implementer and a visionary right so
when she tried all of a sudden she got
upset and started almost crying and she
said
because there's so much attention going
to my son of course and she says
dad it's because you spend more time
with brody than me in the mornings
and i remember just having the immediate
thought that may have came from my dad
or the way i was brought up and i said
to her breed
don't lie to me and don't lie to
yourself that's not true
i i work my butt off to be completely
equal and you're telling yourself a lie
it's not a good story and i went on this
rant
and she tucked it up she stopped tears
she tucked up it was the first time ever
that she left the house without kissing
me goodbye
ever and i'm like well she's just got to
learn that lesson yeah and she left for
about a half hour
and i like it hit me like a ton of
bricks like
i observed that thought i had and what i
basically told my daughter is that
i didn't get about her feelings that it
didn't matter how she felt
right that dad was right tuck it down i
said if she was married to a man
and i watched her try to tell her
husband about her feelings how she was
feeling
and he basically told her to shut up and
tuck it down i'd have a talk with that
dude right
if he's married to my daughter and i
treated my daughter that way i got in my
car because i
only because i'm sharing this because i
practice trying to observe what's going
on why am i feeling this way
what is this thought i'm having step
back look at it when i stepped back and
looked at it i knew i screwed up
i drove this school 100 miles an hour
even if you were right even if i was
right now
i might have been right that i keep
equal time yes but i didn't acknowledge
her feelings
exactly i didn't acknowledge her
feelings i mean that's the gift of
selling it's not what people need it's
what they want how they feel
right so i told her her feelings i drove
to her school 100 miles an hour you were
at chapel remember i came and got you
out of chapel
i got her out of chapel and i walked her
outside and i said dad screwed
up i said i may have been right in
context but i wasn't right and telling
you your emotions mean something your
feelings mean something
and we had a great talk we hugged we
kissed her and i had the best
relationship in the world and
and i left and i felt amazing and she
felt amazing
and i never would have caught that if i
wasn't observing my thoughts so i say
that story about my family my daughter
sitting here right now but who who are
you not you know what
thoughts are clouding your judgment in a
marriage or in a relationship or in your
partnership or trying to get a raise or
taking your life to another level
whatever it is in your life
most of the time it's those thoughts
that are messing with us and if you can
you can observe them you can adjust them
there's probably not much i'm sharing
today you haven't heard before
you've read it in books you've heard it
someplace you've watched a video or a
podcast
but what i'm going to ask you to do for
the first time is actually listen and
apply it
and that's that's been my mission lately
is like i know
there's some of the things success
principles are the same since the
beginning of time
but when is it time to stop being
inspired stop just watching ed and start
just doing what ed does
like when is that time to stop looking
for the next hit of a great podcast the
next hit of
watching tony or dean or ed or andy or
somebody watching
feeling good and then going back to the
same routine what if this was the time
what if this was the interview what if
this was the moment
you said i'm not just going to listen
i'm going to start to do
so when i wake up i do not look at my
phone if i do
it's russian roulette it could be so
first thing i don't look at my phone
second thing i just find something to be
grateful for
but if you've ever done a gratitude
journal and you know you're three months
in you're like i had nothing left i said
my daughter 27 times my fun
my son 42 like you run out of stuff so
for me i just want to be grateful for
the little things
like i wake up and the shits feel good
i'm like wow
feel good or 150 000 people die a day
you didn't die
i'm grateful just sitting here with you
right now the littlest thing
only so it frames your mind in a
gratitude space i'm not talking about a
long meditation i don't have time for
that maybe you do and that would be
great
but i just think of something in that
moment to be grateful for and then
in the next moment i just think of one
win from the day before
because listen as entrepreneurs or if
you're watching this you want another
level of life you kick your own ass more
than anybody could
you work a 16-hour day and you come home
you're like i got nothing done today
you lied to yourself you met you beat
yourself up so it's a moment to go
no yesterday i closed that deal
yesterday i got to meet ed and i know
he'll be a friend for life like
just one thing that's it seconds
gratitude one thing was a win yesterday
then i think of one win for that day
what's one thing i want to accomplish if
i do that little tiny thing
it puts my mind in offense and i'm in a
different space at the end of our life
man we are going to look back and wish
we didn't get mad at one thing
or let things bug us or worry about if
someone took advantage of us we got
this life is going so damn fast
and maybe that's because the age i'm at
now i see how quick it's going i'm going
to be 50 this year that i'm when i'm
recording this and i'm like
wow how did i get the 50 it went like
that
so i got another 50 years left you know
it's like and that's if
you know if everything goes right and
man
what i what if i looked back in my life
and i was at the end of it and i looked
back and said
i remember that day that you sat there
and were furious and pissed off all day
over something that you couldn't control
why'd you waste that day so i want to
ask you
why are you wasting any days especially
on things
people probably have taken advantage of
people probably hurt you in the past
but if you want the millionaire success
habits to go to another level the same
habits that'll bring your joy abundance
happiness
wealth prosperity all together let it go
let it go you might never get the
apology you might never get i'm sorry
you may never get the money back
you may never get what you deserve
but that's okay because it'll come
someplace else remember karma it's not
about getting back from what you gave
just give everywhere and all of a sudden
someone taps you on the shoulder
and behind you without you even know it
was coming come becomes the perfect
relationship comes the perfect business
partnership
comes the money comes the company and uh
the more we can remember that the more
we can practice it
on a regular basis the more success
you'll have in your life
in today's world we are so busy with
social media and our phones sitting next
to us
and facebook and instagram and emails
and text messages
that we're running faster than we ever
have in our entire life
so when you're so busy it's like we have
a cloud around us
and setting goals just doesn't work for
most people in today's crazy fast-paced
world when's the last time you tried to
sit down
and look forward to where you're going
to be in a year or five years it's hard
right
it doesn't work anymore so i want to
give you a little hack don't set goals
create a vision for yourself and here's
how you do it let's pretend it's a year
from now
and you're looking back on your year and
it was the best financial year of your
entire life
you're making the money you want you
have the confidence you want you have
the courage you want you're living in
the house you want you have
the job you want you're treating your
husband your wife your children your
parents the way you want
you're walking around looking younger
feeling better what does that look like
to you
write that down as fast as you can write
down a vision for yourself instead of
looking
forward you're pretending it's a year
from now you're looking back
best year of your life write it down
that's your vision that becomes the new
way to goals
don't create a to-do list everybody has
a list of all these things you want to
do and if you don't make a list
that means you're up in the middle of
night thinking i should do this i should
try this i should get this done i should
get this done and then you come home at
night disappointed because you didn't
have enough time to squeeze it all in so
here's what i'm going to share with you
make a not to-do list your not to-do
list is so much more important
than your to-do list because we're all
too busy when someone tells me
i don't have time or i need a time
management program or i need someone to
teach me how to make a day 36 hours
instead of 24 i'm like no you're just
doing things that don't serve you don't
serve god don't serve your bigger future
don't serve you making more money or
having that business you desire
so as simple as this sounds the
wealthiest people i know the people i
know who've changed the world and
generated billions of dollars when i
look back on my own life
what i realized is i was lucky enough
that i looked at a lot of times of what
should i not be doing
so i encourage you this week make a list
of everything you do and cut out the
stuff that doesn't serve you making more
money your family the universe god
whatever you believe in
because when you take that out then all
of a sudden you can make a to-do list
and actually get it done you win when no
one else is watching is something i've
been telling both of my kids
i bet to say six years seven years
uh about six years when it comes to
playing sports now both of my son plays
baseball my daughter
plays softball they both pitch they're
both really good now because they're my
kids they excel at it
but one thing i've been telling them
forever if you saw my kids if you ever
see me in a live event or i'm anywhere
with my kids
just test me on this and say to my kids
hey how do you win
they'll say two things practice and hard
work and you win when no one's watching
and here's the thing my daughter
loves the praise of winning a game she
loves when she pitches she has the ball
in her hand when everybody's cheering
for her but that doesn't happen at the
game that doesn't happen in public
the reason she's good is because she
practices her guts out when no one's
watching i want to give you a quick
little story it doesn't matter if you're
a parent or not
listen the reason i teach my kids is the
reason i teach you guys this is because
i want it anchored into my life forever
but
forever i mean everybody wants the
praise of the wind
everybody wants the winning business
everybody wants the winning relationship
everybody wants the winning income they
want to win the sports game
but not everybody's willing to put the
time in to work
when no one else is watching so for
example
my daughter last night as i'm recording
this it was last night she played in the
championship game from 11 to 13 year old
girls
fast [ __ ] softball and they weren't
even supposed to be in the finals but
they beat everybody
and now they're playing the number one
team who is undefeated
and the only way they could take first
place is to win twice so they wouldn't
even play the championship game
they didn't win the first one so there's
two pitchers on my daughter's team the
other girl is amazing too great athlete
she's a year older than my daughter she
pitches first then my daughter goes in
and my daughter had the game of her life
she did not give up
one run against the undefeated team i
mean she threw strike after strike and
all her friends came and seen her and
all her friends were saying oh my god
bri you're so amazing you're so lucky to
be that good
and i started hearing these girls they
weren't doing it for just to be
disrespectful
but that's how the world is i heard
lucky or blessed or
gifted she's not gifted my daughter
wasn't my daughter's short for her age
my daughter did amazing last night and
got the praise is because
she won the game when no one else is
watching i go home
four nights a week early because she
wants to throw the ball and i want to be
there and encourage her
she's practicing literally almost every
single day
she could go hang out with friends she
could play video games she could do
something else
but she likes to win and she practices
when no one else is watching in fact in
my office
in my studio where i hold my masterminds
it's big enough
and i'm gonna literally because summers
in phoenix are really crazy it's hot as
hell
i'm putting in this week i'm putting in
a place for her to pitch in the office
because she said i don't want to
lose momentum over the summer dad i want
to come back even better
now that's an amazing lesson i i taught
and i hope
i hope that rubs off on her i'm using
sports as this
foundation for her life but let me ask
you
do you want the glory it's like it's
like wanting to be the rock star
you want to be up on stage jamming and
singing and the crowd going nuts and the
girls going crazy are the guys going
crazy
you want all that but how do you think
those people got on stage
do you think they rehearsed when no one
is watching do you think they packed up
a
crappy old van in some cases and went to
a club where no one showed up no one's
watching but they still played
they still pursued if you want to win
the game of life whatever it is you want
that next level of
relationship income uh doing your own
business
you have to practice and work hard when
no one else is watching
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through that's what we do here
believe nation
we get motivated but then we do
something about it
and when you commit to other people you
increase your chances even further of
following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video and then what is your plan of
action around
for this week put it down in the
comments below because i want to
celebrate
you i just told a story to a dear friend
of mine that i haven't shared in ages
and i always i look back at this story
it's the first time i ever made a
million dollars i was in my 20s it was
on a real estate deal
and i say that now a million dollars to
me then might as well been
200 billion dollars
but i look back and i wonder if i would
be as
creative and as hungry now
as i was when i did that deal
because here's what i know is a lot of
times being successful has a lot to do
with being naive
or not been told being told been told no
to where you start believing what other
people say to not have watching the news
for years so you just want to play small
or
listen to people tell you how now this
isn't the right time not the right
president
you know all these things in life these
outside influences
outside game affects the inner game it
makes you play small without even
realizing like every year you just start
playing smaller and smaller
well i was in my early 20s had no money
i mean when i say no money nothing
right just working hard i was hustling
cars i was fixing wrecked cars and
selling them
and this piece of property came for sale
um
well it actually wasn't for sale it came
for sale because i became friends with
the owner his name was mark
miller he's a famous artist and he owned
28 acres
of vineyards because he owned a winery
and there was an old vineyard had the
grapevine still in it but the weeds had
grown up
and everybody stayed away from this
property because he wanted
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars
and all the neighbors
got so used to the property being vacant
that
one guy shot his bow and arrow he
practiced uh uh
you know his error for archery hunting
he practiced on the property
another guy had his four-wheeler trail
through the whole thing
another guy there was a barn on the
property one of the neighbors kind of
adopted the barn because it was kind of
vacant no one was around so he kind of
adopted the barn and used it and to him
it was his
and the other guy up on the hill just
wanted complete privacy he didn't want
anybody building next to him that's
that's in real estate we call it not in
my backyard i could build a house but i
don't want anybody building in my
backyard right
so everybody stayed away from this
property and plus he was asking maybe a
little bit too much
but mark miller and i the gentleman on
the property became friends
and i made a deal with him to give him
90 000 up front and
90 000 um in two years or a year
something like that
and i was going to subdivide this
property so i didn't have the 90 grand
back then and i told this story or prior
prior to one of my uh clients and friend
uh lent me the money to buy the property
i made him a partner on it
um so i went to mark miller i locked up
the property and
i go through this now i'm sharing this
story specifically take the lessons out
of it
is one of it was being naive and one of
his
and i put this in my first real estate
course which was called think a little
different
because i want to encourage you to think
outside the box life
paints you inside life is forcing you in
at all times we go to
school and they they give us time frames
and buzzers and bells and
and don't talk to anybody else and sit
in your square sit in your
in your world don't stray out don't i
mean in in business if you don't
collaborate with others
you die but in school if you do it it's
called cheating
makes zero sense to me it's like the
world is designed to put you in the box
and the only people who make it to live
at their full potential the ones who
break out of the box so
i'm sharing this story because being
naive being young and being freaking
hungry i mean i was hungry for another
level
there was nobody telling me no made this
a million dollar deal so
buy the property i start going through
the subdivision process and i'm beg bar
and steal i'm hustling cars during the
day to use the money
to pay for this subdivision i have
engineers and architects and
now i gotta lay out the road i'm
learning all this stuff about a big
subdivision it's called a major
subdivision i had done a minor
subdivision which was like
three lots or four lots or less so now
i'm doing a major and all of a sudden
it starts i go to the first planning
board meeting and all the neighbors show
up and they're just
like like like i like i murdered their
children
for lack of a better word they just
despised me
and i'm like wow how am i gonna and you
gotta realize in business
one person upset can stop or cause you
years and i didn't have the money
to to drag this thing out for years and
fight the neighbors and all that kind of
stuff so
they go and one of the guys name was
wade sargent his mother
and my mother were best friends growing
up so
wade was still there fighting me he
didn't want this subdivision to go in
his backyard
so i walked to wade's house one day this
is being hungry
this is being not afraid to go after
your dreams not taking no as an answer
when's the last time
you gave up too easy and someone else
got their dreams maybe with your idea
so i knock on wade's door his name was
wade sergeant i said hey wade what's up
iden
it was kind of like you're my friend but
you're trying to ruin my backyard
uh so i said wade listen i'm gonna make
that subdivision happen
it might take me longer everybody can
fight me i'm gonna make it happen i
don't give up
but how can i make you happy and what he
told me
changed everything he said well i just
really don't want the road to go
close to my backyard if i had a little
buffer
he said i've had a little buffer i'd be
fine i'd support you i'm like well
by buffer you mean if i sold you a piece
of that property
you'd be happy he said yeah would you do
that
i said heck yeah i'll take your money so
i do a lot line revision not even a
subdivision you don't have to know real
estate to understand this
i did a lot line revision and i gave him
a half of an acre and
he cut me a check like wow i went to
all the neighbors the guy that was using
the barn like it was his
carved out an acre and sold them the
barn the guy that wanted privacy i sold
him four acres
another guy wanted a two acre cushion
next door neighbor wanted to
sell some la i wanted to put a house for
his uh daughter on his property someday
i ended up selling over 250
000 dollars worth of lot line revisions
to the neighbors
and all of them happy all of a sudden
all of them from hating me everybody's
staying away from this property
they all love me i was the guy going
down the road they high-fived me they
waved to me
and then guess what then i subdivided
the center piece of property
and sold the center for over eight
hundred thousand dollars
brought in over a million dollars on
this piece of property by making the
neighbors happy
now people much smarter than me
developers in our town
looked at that property told me i was
crazy uh uh
um rick affuso his dad
um told me because he had farmed that
property when he was kid and i respected
him it was a great real estate developer
in our little town
and um he told me you paid 180 for that
property
you just lost your butt you didn't say
butt you just lost your ass he said
and um i was like damn it maybe i did
but they were all looking at it from
inside the box
i was desperate i was hungry i didn't
take no for an answer
and i looked at it completely different
like the name of my first course think a
little
different where in your life right now
are you
inside the box and you don't realize it
and you need to think a little
different that's where change happens
that's where innovation happens
that's where breakthroughs happen that's
when people go holy crap how did he do
that how did she do that
it's by not taking no for an answer not
looking from
looking at it through a set of glasses
that everybody has everybody's got the
same glasses on wear a different pair
look at things differently
go for it don't let the world talk you
into to being complacent
if you want two hours of eric thomas
beast mode motivation check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i don't want nothing from you but
for you to leave his room
and know what you want what do you want
in your marriage what do you want
with your son and your daughter